there's no time o clock hey you guys
it's episode 198 yeah Bob Lazar we're
talking about aliens baby yeah we've
only done like I think in one other UFO
show um wait a minute we did one on
Travis Walton right yeah that's right
and then we did one ultra triangle yeah
did we do a Phoenix lights wanna know we
need to do that hmm I thought we did by
a Phoenix I don't think we did Phoenix
lights or maybe we did one that was like
all together yeah we mentioned Phoenix
lights we probably did but yeah so I've
had like numerous requests to do bob
lazar and like area 51 type stuff so
finally I was kind of like yeah I might
as well since we did like you know a
really creepy true-crime thing last week
so we're trying to like mix it up a
little bit and also because the Netflix
has a very well-known documentary called
bob lazar an area 51 aliens and area
first or something like that and jeremy
Korbel made it I think it came out in
2018 but we just watched that the other
night yeah so um yeah Bob me and Bob go
back for you youngsters I'm gonna go
ahead and give it a give a damn
introduction and kind of set the scene
for what what the whole bob lazar game
was about bob lazar appeared out of
nowhere when I was younger you know I
guess I was no [ __ ] late teens early 20s
he first came on the news in 1989 oh
yeah so late teens early 20s is back
before the internet you could kind of
say anything you wanted to say and I was
real hard to check you just kind of had
to believe what you were being told when
you saw you know when you're
watching it on television and back in
those days man thought bob lazar [ __ ]
he had a wild story and he looked like a
scientist so you kind of believe it it
was it was the big glasses yeah first of
all let me let me say this you know I
know there are extraterrestrials you'd
be an idiot to think that there isn't
life on other planets especially now
there's like these new surveys being
done earth-like worlds are gonna be
common there I think life is gonna be
pretty common on those earth-like worlds
all right even if you're only talking
about 2% of the earth like planets
having a life on that means there's
[ __ ] millions of them still that
means a lot of them okay so yeah there's
extraterrestrials and recently the the
I've always believed that Milton that
the military and the government saw them
there there are some reports that are
very difficult to dismiss and recently
you know as of time of recording this I
think is about two or three weeks ago
the Pentagon came out and said yeah we
see things they showed the videos you
know some of the stuff that they've seen
but they see mysterious objects and
moving and doing things that aircraft
can't do they don't come out and save
their extraterrestrials but you know
there there may be a few other
explanations of what they could be but
based on positive pilots you know
descriptions of [ __ ] that's happened I
can't see how it wouldn't be
extraterrestrial so I think you know I
think we're probably in somebody's
territory to check up on us
you know it's they're not trying to
invade us or anything so just because
you know we might say something crazy
about ba bizarre that don't we're not
implying that we don't believe that
they're extraterrestrials I'm pretty
sure there are you know I know there are
extraterrestrials I'm just saying I'm
pretty sure that they that
extraterrestrial craft come here on
earth seen by military you
I'm gonna go like okay from a
statistical standpoint I think it would
be really unlikely if there wasn't other
life in the universe unlikely again
statistically it's probably follows that
some of them are more technologically
advanced than us yeah as to whether any
of them have visited here I'm less sure
about um if they did I think it was more
something like like you said like a
pilot somebody was just like a drive-by
I don't think any of them have landed
I'm thinking you know I don't think
anybody has like made contact with them
I don't think they probed anyone's anus
I don't think anything like that so
pretty much any people that come up with
stories like that either are making it
up or are mistaken or something like
that I'm not saying that I I don't think
that they have seen like craft or
something like that that's possible um
but I don't think they've crashed or
anything like that so I don't believe it
in that Roswell [ __ ] very very unlikely
that the military or the government has
any knowledge of any of this yeah it's
more likely that they that they're
getting reports that they believe but
there's nothing they can do about it
right and there's what are they gonna
say you know I mean there's besty back
in the day so you don't I mean back in
the 50s and the 60s and said they're not
gonna say look we're the Air Force we're
in charge of keeping you safe by keeping
[ __ ] out of the sky but guess what guess
what we're seeing these crafts that come
from another [ __ ] world and they're
probably millions of years of in advance
of us in terms of technology and there's
nothing we can do about it yes if they
wanted to like just blast us all away to
Kingdom conch app pretty much hose we're
basically fishing a fish tank and
there's somebody walking around sticking
their hand in a tank don't worry about
that's okay you know if they wanted to
eat us they'd to eat this by now that's
what I figure that's not gonna but that
kind of [ __ ] is not gonna reassure the
public yeah so I think that over the
years they probably compiled a bunch of
reports and there's an office somewhere
that keeps track of all that they're
like the guys that keep track of all
that damn information or like yeah
something's coming we don't know what it
is they haven't talked to us that's
probably and I think to you the problem
with it and I think it's probably pretty
why
for them to just come out and say look
we do see things that they're anomalous
we don't know what they are but it would
be dumb to come out and say they're
extraterrestrial because they don't know
inter talked to them it's like you know
it could be anything it's like it could
be a mistake it could be a
misidentification it could be it could
be extraterrestrial but they don't know
so it would be dumb to say that they
knew it was extraterrestrial because
they don't know if it the stuff that's
actual to rest or that they see and some
of the stuff I think is extraterrestrial
just based on the reports because I
because you know he some of this [ __ ]
goes back to the 70s and we couldn't
make this to kind of stuff back in the
seventies no way um but what they're
seeing probably isn't uh what you would
think of as a spaceship which is a damn
you know a [ __ ] interplanetary car
you get in it you drive from one planet
to that's probably where the vacation
plan is probably what you're seeing is
some kind of a probe or a living machine
the chances of them being biological is
very unlikely biology breaks down you
know it dies but machines can live
forever they're immortal so it stands to
reason that eventually biological
entities make intelligent computers and
then those live longer than them like
out of damn movie AI well like you said
I think it's more likely if I was an
extraterrestrial that was like you know
spacefaring that was spacefaring in
several thousand or million years ahead
of Earthlings but I wanted to kind of
keep track of them to make sure they
weren't getting up to any mischief then
you would just build drones why would
you send like one of your people like
one of your extraterrestrial people
would just send a machine and guess but
like hey go check that out I don't think
they're people as we know it I think
they're people in the way that the
monolith was a people in 2001 monolith
with the people yeah I think it's kind
of they're kind of like a superior
almost godlike or uh intellect that's a
machine based and they're not they're
not biological if they're watching us
they don't think that we're all that
important see that's what I think it's
like why the hell like that's why that
another reason why I don't buy like any
of these kind of like oh I was abducted
by aliens or their progeny or anything
like that why the hell would they care
anything that could get here can go
anywhere right so that means we have all
this other [ __ ] the universe we got to
compete against yeah and we're not
interesting like whether yeah why would
we be interesting they they just you
know you you got in your backyard and
you see some bugs on the ground you just
keep walking you don't stop and talk to
the bugs yes you got a place to be you
know so these things are gonna be most
likely living machines and it's not
artificial intelligence this real
intelligence they just happen to be
machine based and they're immortal and
if they're they're just going around
looking at stuff because maybe we're the
nursery basically yeah they they look at
stuff like humans on the planet and they
go yeah that might make it you know and
they might make some artificial
intelligence one day in the computer and
then that might evolve into real
intelligences like us let's just see if
they make any of us yeah and then they
sit back and they sit back well they're
immortal they would be immortal and
they'd be living in kind of like an
Internet so they got all the time in the
world
you know billions of years wouldn't seem
like much to them so you know I mean
they're operating on a totally different
time scale than we operate like you know
the bacteria we have bacteria don't live
a couple days yeah you know to them
that's an entire lifetime for us that's
nothing well that's the difference as
we're talking about we're talking about
vast differences anything that could
come here is is very old very ancient
and I don't think it's biological so
some of this stuff that I think these
pilots are seeing would be like when you
see the damn UFO that's the alien
basically yeah that's how it looks from
your point of view and it maybe like you
said like a drone or a robot but it's
hooked up with an Internet and they can
[ __ ] kind of transport their
intelligence into that thing and it's
kind of they can get like a first-person
view of what's you know I mean of what
the probes do you haven't take control
it's almost like an avatar like an
avatar yeah for the alien the alien is
probably something lives in an inn
that and it's like stretches across the
galaxy so you know an internet that
where you know I mean the information
can flow faster than the speed of light
it's like a quantum type internet
probably existent in a higher dimension
so you know I mean so here is also there
so space and time would be meaningless
to them so the you know they've
conquered all that yeah they're sitting
on expert we're set on novice well yeah
what a barely playing a game that's kind
of like why I think that you know a lot
of the older um you know alien abduction
stories are like alien you know flying
saucer sightings and stuff like that to
me it just seems like it betrays like a
lack of imagination because if there
really are extraterrestrial
intelligences I don't even think that
humans would be able to imagine yeah
what they were up to yeah when you got
these guys from [ __ ] the Ozarks and
stuff you know and they're from Alabama
and they say they got abducted by this
and that you know I mean and it was a
beautiful alien woman that [ __ ] took
interest in there his name's Albert
alien woman one if they wanted him to
impregnate a guy who said that when you
hear [ __ ] like that they're describing a
civilization that would only be like a
couple hundred years or a hundred years
ahead maybe it but socially like 50
years behind us right this is just the
imaginations of a [ __ ] madman that's
not the way it's not the way societies
and aliens would be progressing
they wouldn't evolve like that the the
most accurate description of an
extraterrestrial I can think of is
[ __ ] 2001 Space Odyssey
see that [ __ ] that thing with that
whole movie was vetted by scientists and
Kubrick worked with them all that stuff
that they were working on the moon bases
and the [ __ ] spaceships and they were
all based upon stuff that they were
really good to make yeah that you know
the little you know project Orion got
cancelled and had project Orion happened
they would have been able to get enough
stuff up into orbit where they could
have made all that but you know the
SpaceX is doing pretty good they'll
probably come close to what you see in
2001 in a few decades yeah all the
expense was getting stuff up into orbit
you know they'd really that's that's
what's holding us back but if you've
ever seen 2001 that's what an alien
would be like one that could come here
yeah you know they have animals they
have aliens that are like us but they're
trapped on their planets they can't get
here they're like us they're stuck yeah
I think there's a lot of them they're
just animalistic you know just animals
yeah one of that I mean it stands to
reason that there's a bunch of planets
that have life that's not as quote
unquote evolved as the earth either
really because there's gonna be some
that's like behind yeah way behind or a
lot of the planets will have life on
them but it'll but the life will appear
billions of years from now yeah that
kind of stuff
or it's just microbes either that are
like there's a really like advanced
technological civilization and they're
really into like this interplanetary
show that's kind of like the equivalent
of Jackass so they might come to earth
like kidnap people and then they film it
yeah and then they put it on their
version of YouTube for everyone's
edification and amusement
I would I would think that if there are
any biological entities that were
interplanetary that were traveling
between planets and were fairly advanced
they probably highly genetically
engineered also true so yeah because I
mean we're even heading that way we're
headway now so man a chances are if
they're really genetically engineered
they'd be like something kind of like
the engineers out of Prometheus they
didn't really have any gender they could
live for millions of years not much a
sense of humor I'd be something like
that something that was very stable
emotionally and stuff so they didn't
fight you know or maybe they did fight
yeah I don't know
I was wouldn't think I would think that
you know I think we're still kind of
simian we're kind of ape-like still yeah
something that's maybe a few thousand
years ahead of us when they're doing
with genetic engineering and stuff
they'd be less like us more like them
damn almond-shaped [ __ ] gray aliens
that they're describing that's kind of
kind of probably what we'd involved into
with genetic engineering I'm alright
with that little big head no sexual
organs also there's long grass B fingers
it'd be a totally I would be a totally
PC race now their defense everyone would
be great everyone would be gray every
would be all be the same [ __ ]
genderless kind of thing and you'd be
little and you just sit up there and
[ __ ] let's surf the web that's what
you do that sounds cool actually yeah
but maybe not maybe they've like evolved
to the foot where that's like you know
the pinnacle of like achievement so they
wouldn't get bored maybe maybe they've
evolved beyond boredom you ever think of
that
no I'm not I kind of think being
well-rounded is really the secret to
survival in the universe over time you
know something that you caught a blend
of the best of intellect and aggression
together and into the into one thing
that way you can defend your species
against other species and then and
you're kind of like aggressive where you
take planets and you colonize and
multiply like a virus and spread
something kind of like the damn Klingons
that probably big or the things from
predator baby yeah something like that
or you would totally be a Klingon oh
yeah I love that damn
Conan spacefaring dang out of Conan or
something that could make it would beat
that damn Xena more from alien something
like that I mean yeah if something like
that evolved I think that would very
quickly take it well here's another one
here's another one that would be a very
successful alien um blueprint the thing
from the thing from John Carpenter is
that is like the perfect distillation
that's what you want to mean yeah
because that it's endlessly adaptable
endlessly adaptable you can steal
anything from any other you go anywhere
and apparently they didn't
bring this up I don't think in the movie
but apparently whatever planted it
landed on I mean if it took over your
form then it could had all your
knowledge to well it had all your
knowledge not only that but it could
also like adapt to the environment yet
that you know that organism like you
know lived in we could be anyway that
would be very very handy and then if it
needed more intelligence or more
technologies and that technology just
absorbed it enemy alien and it would
know everything that that alien knew
yeah so it could make spaceships it
could do anything well I think we
probably even mentioned this probably we
did like a review of the thing a long
time ago but I I was thinking like if
something like that landed on the earth
we would be super [ __ ] and it would
not take that long and if that you could
take out you could take over the whole
earth you can take over like [ __ ]
universe as a very brief amount of time
I'm pretty sure Carpenter got that from
Lovecraft I think he's taught I think he
copied that from the shag off yeah yeah
Carpenter was really into Lovecraft eat
a bunch of Lovecraft because the shag
off was kind of described as that yeah
and I think you got it from the shag off
and the blob yeah it was kind of like
the blob - yeah yeah because the blob
couldn't really like it just looked like
a big look like a blob melted popsicle
but it goes and took over yeah it's just
like absorbed everybody and just got
bigger and bigger like just from
absorbing it just look like a big city
or whatever so we're gonna get to Bob
here in a minute is there yet any
shoutouts or any I just had a couple of
shoutouts I wanted to give another thank
you to Zanna da ya who gave us a PayPal
donation so thank you very much for that
we also have a new patron Jonathan H so
hey there thank you very much you guys
any support is good support we like to
keep the show going and like I said I
think I mentioned this on the last
week's show but if you've noticed hope
you guys are liking the matinee the way
I'm breaking up the matinee show into
one movie chunks instead of just like
dumping them all in one show so probably
there'll be one went up Sunday I'm gonna
try and still do three a week but I'm
just gonna put them up set
just on one show and then on the days
when I don't put anything up we'll put
aside tracks so that's kind of our plan
for the future because like I said we we
were doing side tracks every day and I
know a lot of people like those but it
did seem like some days we were just
kind of like what the hell are we gonna
talk about and then you know what I mean
I didn't just want to like put something
up for the sake of putting putting
something up but we didn't have anything
to talk about
so probably we'll just do them once or
twice a week when we don't have a movie
going but that's probably all the
shoutouts I think that I have so let's
talk about the very famous Bob Lazar
yeah now okay so we just watched this
documentary which okay so this
documentary came out in 2018 it's on
Netflix if you want to watch it it was
made by Jeremy Korbel who also made a
documentary about skinwalker ranch which
I haven't seen and he also made one I
think it was called patience 17 that was
about that you know that doctor that
says he takes out like alien implants
from people that say they've been
abducted yeah that guy yeah okay so he
made a documentary about that too so
this guy is a UFO believer even though
in this the Bob Lazar documentary he
kind of tries to make it come across
like he's sort of skeptical and stuff I
kind of got the feeling that he was
trying to look like he was being
objective but not really another funny
thing about that guy that made the
documentary and if you watch the
documentary he's in most of it like it's
not it's about bob and george knapp is
in there too and we'll get into a little
while later these guys but these guys
were endlessly entertaining during the
damn yeah during the uh during the Art
Bell era yeah used to listen to our bell
and when they had [ __ ] either one of
these guys on it because they were on
all the times like Super Bowl for you
old-timers that remember radio [ __ ] I
remember I'd be [ __ ] listening to
listening to [ __ ] art Bell and Bob
Lazar and all these guys on the radio
and then surfing the web through Web TV
on my television back in the day it was
kind of an eerie feeling yeah they're
very beginnings of the early internet it
was a trip I felt like I was in the
future
I was doing [ __ ]
the running man I'm in the future only
it's right now yeah yeah
yes but yeah so another thing that made
me laugh about the Jeremy Korbel guy was
that he's also I guess he does like MMA
fighting
Tet style or whatever and he has
developed a style of fighting or
something which he calls are gonna love
this quantum Jiu Jitsu yeah okay
and he goes under the any and he goes by
sensei just like Steven Seagal [ __ ]
even though yeah even though I I will
say to be fair Jeremy Korbel does look
like he could probably kick your ass
unlike Steven Seagal looks like he could
probably just sit on you girls taking
pictures of it yeah and then he'll come
over and like makes a little quip yeah
don't make gym one day gone experience
what are these days Steven Seagal is
gonna show up on our doorstep please get
her Frank our tour o unity you're gonna
[ __ ] you're you're gonna plot the
[ __ ] camera definitely get that [ __ ]
on tape that's going right on the show
being focused ago getting out there
squaring off kicking these those ass
I'll take my shirt off okay this needs
to happen terminator glasses my plan a
tease tracks well yeah I would
definitely have to like put some like in
these power ballad in the backers like
that you know cuz you're a man your man
cuz you're a man is not a lady this
definitely needs to happen now
come on sit I'll show up at our house
I'll give you the address let him prove
to me you are so ok so the thing about
Bob Lazar now he first came to
prominence as I said in 1989 he appeared
on a Las Vegas TV like a news program KL
klas and he was talking to George Knapp
who was an investigative journalist
there at the time now the first time
that Bob Lazar appeared on TV he was
like in shadow you know what I mean and
he gave the pseudonym Dennis now his
story was that I can't remember if he
actually came out and said that he was a
physicist but he did say that he worked
at a place called s4 which was near area
51 and that he had been tasked with
reverse engineering alien spacecraft
that the government were keeping there
like they wanted to know how it worked
and they hired him to come in there and
find out how they worked like his street
reverse and you essentially so that
already a problem so that was his story
and he also said later that he had been
privy to some classified documents that
said that these aliens had been here for
10,000 years and that they had been they
were from Zeta Reticuli which
incidentally it was the same place that
Betty and Barney Hill said that said
that their aliens were from that
abducted them back in the 50s yeah
clearly yeah so he said they've been
here for 10,000 years and that you know
the government knew about them and
they'd been like using their technology
and there was this kind of thing but
they had like I think he said they had
nine spacecraft at this facility and
he's kind of gone back and forth over
whether he actually saw any aliens or
not because I think at one point he said
oh I just glanced over and I saw like a
little
figure that he implied could be an alien
but then when they asked him about it
like on the recent documentary he said
oh well I just got a glance it might
have just been something else he did say
that he got to go in one of the ships
and tried to sit in one of the seats in
the flying saucer but it was like really
little like it was children's eyes yeah
so he's implying that these are little
low Betty aliens yeah now here's the
thing I was gonna say here's the thing
there's a whole bunch of things there's
a whole bunch of things like wrong with
this story my life 17 18 19 yourself
didn't really question it all that much
the fact that maybe like a guy who how
old was he maybe he's maybe at 26 27th
of time something like that yeah maybe a
little bit older but he would have been
basically hired off the street yet I
mean yeah try to [ __ ] figure out how
a UFO works okay I I did that didn't
just stop me in my tracks back then but
I hear it now and I just like well
that's because you have to understand
something there's a bunch of [ __ ]
contract there's a bunch of companies at
the US government contracts to do really
[ __ ] high-tech [ __ ] that guess like
Lockheed Martin okay yeah head [ __ ]
yeah you know Boeing Grumman Aaron Roman
Aerospace and you know my granddad
worked for Grumman and he worked for
[ __ ] Bo and you also work for General
Atomics back in the day
my granddad worked on a Saturn 5 project
my granddad [ __ ] helped engineer a
lot of the [ __ ] f-14 Tomcat and got
sent to Iran and my granddad's family
all my aunts and [ __ ] he got sent to
Iran
Isfahan to help a Shah trained his men
to [ __ ] learn how to [ __ ] maintain
f-14s and this is time this isn't a time
before the ayatollah khomeini through
the Cutt overthrew the country that's a
whole story in itself maybe one day I'll
do a short show on that yeah you said
that's actually my family was in the
[ __ ] Iranian Revolution some of my
aunt's were the last American citizens
to get out of that embassy before the
you know the hostages were taken if they
needed somebody to figure out how a UFO
it wouldn't be some dude off the [ __ ]
street it'd be those companies were like
pro football teams they had [ __ ]
famous dudes with [ __ ] long track
records a success of building some
wild-ass [ __ ] and they all knew each
other and they traded they traded
between companies like theirs oh you
know we need you know we need Ron who's
wrong Ron's with General Atomics bring
him over here let's just see if we can
get him out of there we needed him to
work on this and they were just a bunch
of Imagineers they could imagine it and
[ __ ] engineer it there were no
computers but during my granddad's day
it was all [ __ ] slide rules yeah
they'd go to [ __ ] night clubs and get
drunk and write [ __ ] down on napkins and
talk about blowing [ __ ] up but they were
making sure but there's a big crowd of
them so nobody could hear what they were
talking about you know they were
speaking in codes trying to come up with
you know what's the best way to spray
fuel instead of a combustion chamber
they were like hot rodders more than
they were this they were not computer
geeks okay
these dudes also you know [ __ ] had
[ __ ] heavy engineering and heavy
[ __ ] mathematical skills they can
just do [ __ ] algebra on their heads
they were that kind of guy okay all wore
ties ties and coke bottle glasses that's
what they were like
back in my granddad's day well that cut
those guys were still around in when
Lazar is talking about yeah okay and
they had come off all these [ __ ]
badass projects some of them that'll
never see the light of day external
combustion engines and [ __ ] they would
have called one of them guys to figure
out how a UFO works when when to Ben
some dude off the street okay yeah dudes
that's what I mean good at that [ __ ]
there are a huge amount of like holes in
the story but that is one thing that
always kind of bothered me about it is
that you know they had like a very large
roster of people that already worked for
them like works in military capacity and
worked for like other contractors that
the military used they had dudes with
expertise in exactly that area if indeed
there was an alien spacecraft that they
wished to reverse-engineer which I do
not believe then they would have had
like a very deep pool of talent to the
approach to ask to do that rather
just hiring a guy random [ __ ] a
random [ __ ] right even if he had
been as he claimed to MIT and Caltech
which I also do not believe and that
wouldn't be enough that community really
didn't care too much about [ __ ] what
school you went to thee they cared about
what projects you you'd come off of last
in other words you know I mean some of
those dudes started I'll be back in the
end and part of World War two yeah so
it's mostly about their past
accomplishments on on on projects that's
what mattered to them more anything else
you know I mean coming out of some
school that wasn't enough for them you
know what I mean you have to think that
if there was indeed alien technology and
they wanted to figure out how it works
the priorities that would be one
priority right it would be - it would be
really really top see yeah yeah and they
had dudes they had the right kind of
dudes for that that come off all kinds
of top-secret projects even even more
secret than the sr-71 they have projects
that were even more secret that had
never seen the light of day that nobody
knows about
yeah but guys have come out and said oh
now that ain't [ __ ] there's stuff you
didn't know about so no they wouldn't
have asked it Oh Bob
it would have been people that they've
been working for for them working with
for thirty years forty years and they
would make that priority one they would
pull all those dudes off of whatever
projects they were on and put them on a
damn UFO project and they and and they
would be [ __ ] thrilled to be on that
project
well yeah can you imagine like how
[ __ ] cool that would be if that was
your career and you'd been like in that
scene your whole entire life and they
said hey gettin what there's a there's
for real aliens real aliens and you need
to figure out yeah and you get one guy
in there and they'd ask him they'd say
oh who do we need who should we who do
we need to get on it you know to figure
this out and that one contractor would
[ __ ] go oh we need [ __ ] Ron we
need [ __ ] Bob we need [ __ ] Mike
they're all [ __ ] first-name basis
especially back in those days it was a
small community of them you know and I'm
saying small you're talking about a few
thousand of them but they knew they knew
each other yeah well you don't have to
you it's they all worked amongst the
same companies you know we try yeah it's
just like any kind of specialised field
where you know even if you don't know
that person directly like you know
someone who knows
yeah you know what I mean like
everyone's kind of known by reputation
yeah and here's the deal if they got
their hands on a [ __ ] UFO from
another planet even those guys probably
better figure it out I don't think so
not if it was it as advanced and it was
so advanced that it get here across you
know [ __ ] interstellar space through
warp technology and [ __ ] they probably
wouldn't know what they were looking at
I'm thinking probably not I mean you
know it there might be a couple people
that would be able to figure out but
really not very many I would think
interplanetary [ __ ] warp drive type
spaceships if something like that really
exists which I think they probably do
you're gonna run into some weird [ __ ]
that you hadn't thought of you're gonna
run into [ __ ] like you see the ship
sitting there you know what I mean it's
the size of a RV but when you open it up
it's the size of a battleship in other
words it's bigger on the inside than it
is on the outside you're gonna run into
that it's artists like a TARDIS you're
gonna run into [ __ ] like that
and I don't think there's gonna be any
human alive that's gonna be able to
figure what the [ __ ] how would you even
start with that like you know just like
over a wheel like well I'm still yeah
yeah man you're gonna go down and you're
gonna look for the engine room you'll
find it you'll never find it you're like
there's no engine
yeah there's no combustion there's no
you know then you might find a room that
just them looks like a damn crystal with
a [ __ ] bunch of rays coming into it
you know I mean how are you gonna figure
that out that's what I mean it it really
seems like it would be too difficult
yeah a job and then you [ __ ] go well
the power source of this that's driving
this must not be in this dimension it
must be coming out of a higher dimension
a direction we can't point to so most of
the machine isn't here
most of the machine is in another
dimension how are you gonna [ __ ]
figure that out right yeah like I said
there was I would be very surprised if
there that's probably what you're gonna
be dealing with and you're talking about
a machine that can go across those
distances in a reasonable amount of time
yeah that's probably what you're talking
about and I mean the thing about it - so
so Bob says that there's nine saucers
and he was in there working on trying to
reverse-engineer them he actually did a
sketch of one of them on the dock
memory and it looked pretty much like a
standard flying saucer like you would
see you know just add it out of anybody
that would like that's been abducted or
whatever the one that he drew he usually
calls that one the sport model which for
some reason made me laugh really hard um
he said that it looked like metallic
like a lot of them was then it looked
like it was made kind of out of
stainless steel but it was something
different to that now so so like I said
the first time he was on the news you
know he was anonymous but then like a
few months later he came out with his
own name and all of a sudden kind of
[ __ ] now after he came out with his own
name he started making claims that the
government was mad at him for like
blowing the whistle on all this UFO
stuff he said that he had been shot at
he said that he was like under
surveillance and all this other kind of
stuff again which I'm not really sure
how much of that I believe now one thing
that one claim that he did make and this
is kind of significant because it kind
of came into play later on who was that
he claimed that the ship was powered by
a chemical element chemical element 115
now at the time he made this claim that
chemical element had not been they had
never made it like in a lab it wasn't on
the periodic table of the elements yet
you know what I mean so he said that
that was he he'd he said that it was a
very very heavy element that it was it
was like some kind of propulsion system
like an antigravity type of thing and
that it was fueled by a stable isotope
of this particular element now
significantly before it was discovered
because like I said the periodic table
of the elements they they have like
provisional you know numbers and like
names for elements that haven't been
discovered yet that they think that it's
like you know it's probably out there
but they haven't made it in a lab or
they haven't found it or anything like
that but so they do have like little
names and stuff so 115 when he made this
claim was actually provisionally named
onion pentium however in 2003
Russian scientists actually made some in
a lab so they called it Muscovy now the
thing about Muscovy him though is that
yes it was a very heavy element which
you know that's you know he knew a lot
about chemistry so he was just guessing
because that was like the area of the
periodic table that it was on which you
know consisted of other heavy elements
so he just assumed that that's what it
was
however they have yet to find any kind
of stable isotope of this particular
element they've only been able to
they've only been able to make I believe
only 50 atoms of this stuff and their
half-life is point six five seconds so
it vanishes as soon as you make it and
it is highly highly radioactive
so they said pretty much anything you
know any to anything that you're
claiming the they're using this like to
power somebody they're like not
impossible but extremely extremely
unlikely due to the nature of this
element so I'm kind of thinking that
because that element had not been
discovered yet that he was just kind of
winging it when he said that it was like
whoa that we haven't discovered this one
so I'll just say that it's that I'm
because like I said he did know a lot
about chemistry and in fact he still
owns a business where he like sells
chemicals and various other things which
has gotten him in trouble a few times
we'll get into that later but there's so
there's a really old site and that I
found and I didn't want to get like too
much into like physics or science or
anything like that because it's like
people this eyes would glaze over but
there's a really old site it's I think
it's that are they blew fire so if you
just like search blew fire Bob Lazar you
should be able to find it it's most of
the articles are really old they're like
from before 1997 but there was an update
I think in 2018 like when the when the
documentary came out but there's like a
whole bunch of links to articles with
like real physicists and like stuff like
that like kind of taking down his claims
so if you know anything about chemistry
if you know anything about physics or
anything like that you can go read that
stuff and you can see that a lot of the
claims that he's making about the wave
this you know alleged flying saucer was
propelled would not work like very
likely would not work and they're not
saying that it's impossible because yes
it's alien technology and maybe it's
something we don't understand and stuff
like that but they're just saying one
physicist that I saw in there was like
um he's like I'm not saying it's
impossible but given everything that we
know about physics and chemistry and
stuff like that it's really really
really unlikely that it would work the
way he said it works because he's
basically saying that it was like not
not making a wormhole but it was like it
was like making it gravity and
anti-gravity protons or some like that
it was like pulling your destination
like towards yourself essentially is
what he was saying that this ship could
do yeah when he describes the internal
workings of it it's all very vague he's
yeah this module somehow interplays with
this module over here we don't know how
they're connected and then this one
makes this one do something and we
didn't really and then it works so it's
just if they hired him to figure it out
he didn't if he did because like yeah
like you said his descriptions are very
vague yeah and for somebody who
supposedly has a master's degree in
physics from MIT and a master's degree
in electronic technology from Caltech a
degree which they do not offer which I
should point out he really doesn't seem
to know very he knows enough about
physics and chemistry to sound to
[ __ ] you yeah to sound like kind of
like he knows what he's talking about
but everything that I've read from like
actual scientists that have actual
master's degrees from MIT and stuff like
that or are like he's he just sounds
like an intelligent layman like but he
doesn't really know what he's talking
about and it's like some of the mistakes
that he makes her really are really like
simple to debunk yo uh his description
of how the UFO worked kind of reads like
the description of a flow chart like
there's this and and then it's connected
to that and it does this and it does
and that's because that's how he
invented the engine invented it like a
flowchart but in reality if you were
presented with these with this engine
that he's talking about how could you
know it was doing that if you can't if
you didn't understand the interplay
between the two yeah you know I mean it
would be like if you didn't know how an
engine worked okay
well I'm trying to make a good analogy
to that how could you accurately
describe what was going on in an engine
you know if you didn't know anything
about it internal combustion you didn't
know what a piston was yeah because if
you're looking at it it's not not being
all that obvious so he was saying this
does this and this is connected to this
and it does this and it does this but we
don't know how it does it well then how
do you know what these do right you know
what I mean yeah because you're just
kind of like making up there anybody
know like there's no link between
writing things like if you can't prove
that they're linked in this process is
happening then you can't prove what each
one of those object is doing inside that
engine yeah because he wrote it down it
like a flowchart yeah what he thought
would have to happen you know but which
is that's kind of it well it's kind of
interesting that he would do that and
you know telling that he would do that
because that's like I said he's not a
dummy it's like he does know a lot about
chemistry
he um you know ever since he was a kid
he was really interested in like rockets
and jet fuel and stuff like that like he
had a bicycle that had like a jet engine
on the back he had a car with a jet
engine all this other kind of stuff so
he's good at like building things he's
good at like making you know chemical
things he's you know got into trouble
for like you know firework dealing
fireworks and stuff like that but so I
think that he's just extrapolating the
way that an engine works right yeah and
he's extrapolating that to an
interplanetary right type of engine
right he said none of those components
were physically connected to one another
that one interacted are acted on another
through some kind of a field that they
couldn't detect you can't detect the
field and how do you know what's
happening in all this right how do you
know that their inner
how they're interconnected I know what
each one of those components does if you
came can detect the field that happens
in between the two right so you're just
it's just conjecture yeah you hey so you
they wouldn't be able to prove what was
happening he made it up he just made it
up I think he did too and like I said
it's the crazy thing about it is that
like you said maybe back in 1989
you know her early 90s like before there
was an Internet you could get away with
a lot more [ __ ] um you could go on the
news and say you were a physicist that
you had worked at area 51 and s4 he'd I
don't think he said he worked at area 51
exactly but s4 which is like near there
um so you can say you worked there you
said you saw the alien spacecraft you
said all this and people were like I
don't you know people didn't a lot of
people didn't like believe him but I
think he sounded kind of credible it
almost sounded kind of credible and he
did come across as a very intelligent
guy he's very well-spoken he did kind of
sound like he knew what he was talking
about it sounded sort of reasonable what
he was saying but the more people
started looking into his background and
this is crazy too so like I said so he
said he went to MIT he said he went to
Caltech now neither one of those schools
have any record of him obviously he you
know it doesn't look like he got a
degree there he's not in any of the
yearbooks none of the teachers that you
know the professors that were teaching
there at the time remembered him he
claims in black erases history right but
the thing about it is that okay so they
pulled his high school records now his
he did go to high school he graduated
from high school he only took one
science class it was chemistry he
graduated in the bottom third of his
class they're like look if you graduate
in the bottom third MIT or Caltech
you're not going to take that's just not
how that works
no um so that's another thing he did the
only school that has a record of him is
Phillips or what the hell is it called
so it's um gee it's a junior college he
took some chemistry or some electronics
or you know technical type of classes
there in the late 70s and there was a
professor there that remembered him but
that is as far as I know
the only like secondary education that
he had and like he said he claimed later
that his whole entire educational
background had been erased but they're
like could they really erase all of the
yearbook all of the people's memories
like all of the it's like none of the
other students they're recognized him he
didn't have a thesis like he's like if
you got a master's from MIT you have to
write a thesis you would have to have
you know some kind of an intelligence
agency wouldn't try to erase your
background like that what they would do
is they just try to discredit you with
something that happened recently right
but they would do they would de frame
you for rape that be something that they
would do frame you for rape well yeah it
just seems like their son here you you
have to [ __ ]
there would be easier ways to do that
because if you had actually gone to you
know such high profile colleges as those
yeah people would remember you and like
I said if you got a master's degree you
have to write a thesis to do that and
there and those are all on file right
you know what I mean and you have to
have like an adviser for that and you
have to have like so someone would have
remembered him and nobody does yeah
now another thing is that they're pretty
sure that he didn't work at you know the
area 51 but he worked there but not for
like the main company he worked there as
like a technician of some kind like
nothing you know real technical or
anything they they hired them like some
kind of electronics technicians like I
get stuff like fix [ __ ] like fix
computers and fix that kind of crap he
worked there but it was for an outside
contractor so the pretty much the sole
proof that George Knapp and all these
other people come out with that say yes
he worked at this facility was there
like look his name is in the phone book
like the phone directory but the next to
his name
it says K M like k /m that stands for
Kirk mayor I think is the name of the
company and that's an outside contractor
that was they would bring in like just
these electric tech and like I saw this
one documentary where they had like an
ad they said they ran this ad
the paper like all the time like looking
for Electronics Technicians
to work for Kirk Maher and you would go
to all these other facilities and like
fix their computers and [ __ ] like that
so it he was doing [ __ ] like that he
didn't have any security clearance he
didn't have anything like that so you
know he wasn't working at that main
facility is a higher capacity
essentially so it's like yes he did go
in that facility he did know like the
layout of it and [ __ ] like that
but he wasn't like in any official
capacity what's funny is that nowadays
you know I mean they got guys doing that
there with no education at all just
setting up a computer yeah mit is
enquirer you like a special education
now that's glorified janitor yeah well
you know it's setting up people's
computers right as far as I know it's it
was just I think the job that he was
hired for like I said before the ad that
I saw was just like electronics
technician or something like that what
does that mean I mean that could mean
anything that can be changing lightbulbs
it could mean a that's what he was yeah
well like as far as I know I think what
they're talking about is glorified
janitor as far as I using light bulbs
[ __ ] maybe replacing light switches
they did call him like a fix-it guy so I
don't know if he was fixing computers or
if he was just fixing other like
electronic electric [ __ ] around the
janitor you know what I mean it seems
something like that I'm not sure exactly
like what his job was maintenance man
but yeah but he's but he did work there
but only in that capacity because the
thing about it is that as far as I can
determine he did go to that junior
college and he did take some classes
like in you know computer technician and
stuff like that but I don't know if he
got like a degree or anything but back
in those days you know I mean the
average person couldn't format a hard
drive yeah yeah I mean you'd have to go
to school learn how to do that nowadays
you could look that up on the [ __ ]
Internet real quick I don't people don't
format hard drives anymore and I think
that's all obsolete but it wasn't that
hard I could do it yeah I had a service
tech walked me through it one time over
the telephone
one time and then after that if I could
do it from there from there on out
remember
formatting hard drives yeah Oh something
Mallinson that's been a long time since
a long time yeah I thought about doing
that but like that was considered to be
like some high speed [ __ ] back in the
day well I think well I mean when
computers first kind of became
ubiquitous yeah there was a lot of you
know especially like older people that
just didn't have any [ __ ] clue yeah
like how they were I went to a job offer
at one time you know after I got out of
the army the guy was singing do you know
how to use [ __ ] windows what yeah he
didn't believe me the Boston you know
using one yeah now they teach you that
[ __ ] when you're a [ __ ] really what a
babies babies no headaches computers but
you know I mean in 96 that was like you
know 95 96 I think there was a rare
skill but I had a home computer yeah
yeah oh man yeah I think we got our
first computer in 95 or so you think you
know how to use Windows say yeah you
think he can run Excel and he goes yeah
it was kind of a boring him what I've
learned that in a couple of it he didn't
think I can learn that it's crazy
now everybody she didn't know how to do
it everybody knows that he use that how
to do it's just like that my office
spaces here that movie office space
office space yeah just like a movie out
of office space you know mmm yeah okay
Bob you know it's like that you know
it's just hilarious to think yeah it's
like now it's now you you have to know
how to use yeah do all of that [ __ ] or
else you're not yeah job at all he
thought it was too young and just out of
the army they ain't how to use a
computer this is no I got one that's
hilarious
sis I could do that yeah he's like what
yeah he was like 50 you're a man he was
like 50 you know how to do that it is
you is this yeah I'm for my hard drive
and has a you know he thought that was
just like some super high-tech skill
that you had to [ __ ] have a four-year
degree to understand until like totally
played that up is it I think you're some
kind of like technical genius well I
just sit and that's pretty easy stuff
and he looked at me like huh well that's
very funny that's not 96 was a
[ __ ]
but yeah it's funny to think about now
like I said because everybody I mean
that's a basic skill yeah I mean you had
you have to know how to do
yes you have to what I do on my little
[ __ ] tablet okay is far it more
complicated than anything I was ever
doing on the on [ __ ] like a gateway
2000 back in [ __ ] you know 95 96 [ __ ]
man I remember using a [ __ ] Apple 2e
back yeah I was in third grade
yeah plan user dreams in 1978 yes 1978
with a big old five and a quarter floppy
yeah wizardry to land wagon train yes I
think wagon train was a little bit later
but yes boys we were mostly like doing
that little turtle game you had the one
cuz you had it we didn't have windows
back then you had to like write your own
code write code ship because in basic
yeah cuz it wouldn't do anything
otherwise it was just like the little
cursor would just blink at you yeah you
type something in there no now what I
knew it I know back there what I know
now or [ __ ] I would have [ __ ] I
would have driven that old man crazy
because I was I was trying to be polite
and as soon as he started [ __ ]
treating me that way I should have known
that I wasn't getting gonna get the job
so I might as well go ahead just kept
[ __ ] with it yes you know how to do
that he says yeah you can't teach an old
dog new tricks I should have just hang
on what are you [ __ ] stupid soon as
the new century are you from yeah really
soon as soon as I picked up that
skepticism from him I should have just
[ __ ] went right in on him
yeah just [ __ ] should've gone pure
testosterone it says you're too old to
learn that aren't you you minute you
don't want to hire me I'll replace you
how much you makin seventy five thousand
sheet I'll do your job for 40 Oh where's
your boss
I should have really hit that [ __ ]
work that would have been hilarious yeah
kick in the floor as you go home [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah that's right yeah yeah so you know
what it's it really weird to it's like I
was reading this other side was I think
it was that blue
fire site and it had like this time law
like a bob lazar timeline like from the
[ __ ] birth onward now you know
obviously the school thing is probably
[ __ ] even though like I said even to
this day he claims that it's just
because the government like a racist
records and all this other stuff but I
was like I said I don't I don't buy that
because there's just too much other
stuff it's not just it's not just a case
of oh we just destroyed your school
records like I said there would have
been people that you went to school with
you professor stuff like that who would
have remembered you
you would have been in the unit of the
yearbook all this other kind of stuff
and you know none of that was there
tracked on all the alumni and goes give
me your old yearbook here's your other
here do you take that yeah that's a just
gonna like switch about yeah people
decide that yearbook now here's your new
yearbook like that's just not no it's
yeah it's reality is no it's it would
just be too much trouble if someone
wants to shoot you down because you
causing trouble they don't arrest you
race your past they accuse you of a
crime the best one is some kind of rape
or they just have you murdered and make
it look like an accident
yeah like in a wreck or something I mean
I'm just saying like it is over if yeah
if they really really wanted you to shut
up they would make you shut up and it
would look like you it would make they
would like make it look like a suicide
or make it look like an accident they
don't really have to do that they call
you into the office they call you into
the object and they have a [ __ ]
talking with you start throwing here you
know
well here's your mom here's your dad if
a pictures of everyone you know [ __ ]
then they suck and you know I mean then
they say we could hurt you or we'll help
you
it'd probably offer you a job to shut
the [ __ ] up that's like it would
probably be the best if you keep so long
keep talking we're gonna go after your
family if you shut the [ __ ] up we'll
give you a job [ __ ] $50,000 yeah you
don't have to do anything just get off
the show for good yes right and then
we'll just like [ __ ] mom we'll just
give you like yeah two hundred fifty
thousand dollars a year and you just sit
there do ya that's what there's word
around all day well yeah well see that
would be a lot more likely to work with
me like if I knew some top secret
information which is yeah it's just like
if they came to me and said hey we'll
give you half a million dollars a year
just sit in an office and do not think
I'd be
alright I'll Center for that I won't
tell anybody nothing you're coming back
to work with us as for we're gonna get
you $150,000 a year just sit in the
office and shut the [ __ ] up yeah I'd be
like yes sir I can do that
free internet yeah and and [ __ ] me
retire in 20 I was like throwing some
for coffee and cupcakes and I'm but yeah
so but but another thing that's weird
and I said this doesn't get brought up a
lot but I just saw it like on this
timeline thing is that even though I'm
pretty sure that he claimed that he was
born in Florida I believe it was Coral
Gables but the weird thing about it is
that there's he does have a birth record
and then there was a thing about where
they couldn't get his while other people
can't get your birth certificate like
unless it's you or unless it's like your
legal guardian or whatever so then it
was like some thing about well maybe
it's hard to get because he was adopted
but the weird thing is that his social
security number I don't know his whole
social security number but just the
first three numbers that like usually
says what like what state it was issued
in um the state that it was issued in
was in New York so why would he have
said that he was born in Florida if his
social security number was issued in New
York because usually I mean don't I'm
not sure how it works exactly but don't
they usually just issue your social
security number like when you're born or
do you have to like your parents have to
do that right like and most of the time
it happens like right after you're born
like they go and register your social
security number I think so I mean that's
how I always thought it works
I've had mine my whole life so I don't
know uh yeah me too it's like I don't
remember having to do that it's like my
parents did it when I was born I would
assume so I don't know why I'm not
saying I'm not saying that he's lying
about where he's born I'm just saying
it's very odd that he said he was born
in Florida but his social security
numbers from New York and his parents
like lived in New York State so I'm not
really sure like I don't see why he'd be
lying about that unless he just like
lies about everything just reflexively
he didn't know maybe not maybe he was
born here and like I said I'm not sure
if he was adopted I heard somebody else
say that maybe he was adopted but I
haven't heard like much about that maybe
maybe he was born here and then like he
like he was adopted by maybe his parents
are in New York and down here
born down here and then they came and
got him and then they registered his
yes or something like that so yeah I'm
not real sure about that I just thought
that was one thing that when I was
reading that timeline it just came
across as really odd to me I'm like oh
my god is he lying about what state he
was born seems really weird try some
kind of explanation for it yeah so you
know are we at the hour yes we are so
probably we should take a break at the
moment you probably need more to drink
although I've got quite a bit left so
we're gonna take a break right now when
we come back we'll talk a little bit
more about bottles are about alien
spacecraft about area 51 all that kind
of fun stuff yeah what's that face ring
good all right we'll be back in just a
couple minute how you doing boo keys in
the bowl oh my goodness it's storming
outside it's gonna storm pokey yeah look
at that little face look at that little
face she's like stop filming
she's like I'm right we'll look at you
yeah it's thundering outside you love
true-crime
I love true-crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
babies case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
all right we're back talking about
aliens bob lazar yeah area 51 all that
kind of [ __ ] yeah we're getting into his
story this guy is it all right I got a
[ __ ] bag on Bob he seems like a nice
man
no II it was a good store it was
entertaining yeah I kind of feel like
because we were talking we were watching
the documentary like a couple of nights
ago and I was like okay obviously his
story is [ __ ] now do I think that
he's just delusional or do I think that
he's just making up a story like he made
up a story like a long time ago when he
was young and he's like well [ __ ] now
I'm like laughs yes I think it is and
he's like I just can't go back on it you
know what I mean like a fool so he's
just got a double down triple down
quadruple down yeah and because he
doesn't seem like crazy he doesn't seem
like delusional or you know I think he
took ante or anything I think he told a
good tale when he was young and hit a
stick with it can you imagine yeah never
do anything like that
yeah because you come up with some crazy
ass [ __ ] story like that like hey I
worked on reverse engineering like [ __ ]
a lien spacecraft when you're in your
20s or whatever and then like 40 years
later people are still asking you about
that [ __ ] and then it's like you can't
come out I mean because his whole career
his whole shtick is like based on him
going to like UFO conventions and like
everybody you know talks about it was
imagine what would happen if he if they
were to ask him [ __ ] you know I mean
like a year ago or today oh did that
really have it no I was just [ __ ]
with you guys do you realize how much
hate he would get from the entire US
yeah he would get like like death right
for years I've been believing my own
money
you know I [ __ ] I got so many
autographs photographs of you that I
spent $40 a pop at the convention they'd
never be able to live it down
you can't back off of it this is why
this is that's his that's his show this
is why you shouldn't [ __ ] don't come
don't [ __ ] stories when you're a kid
folks cuz you see if you get famous
you're gonna get stuck into that [ __ ]
forever and then you're just gonna have
to keep on with it yeah you can't ever
come out and say that you're just made
it up yeah and I saw a poltergeist when
I was a kid I'm sticking to the [ __ ]
story
[ __ ] know it happen but I didn't say
that I got hired by a [ __ ] thing that
you know yeah your government to [ __ ]
fix a UFO or figure out of wrecking and
you're not something I didn't understand
and didn't explain every bail saw it and
you're not going around like on the
[ __ ] lecture circuit or love famous
about the art Belle show or nothing like
that no I would say how much how much
money have we made off the [ __ ]
poltergeist story
hardly any thousand well actually maybe
maybe they're probably not even that
naive Annette I mean that was over a
period of years yeah because I mean we
wrote that book like yes ago they didn't
sell too many copies it really didn't
but we didn't do it for that
no we just did it cuz well I wrote it
cuz I thought it was an interesting
worry cuz we talked about it a long time
and I was just like I just thought it
was an interesting story I don't care
people don't believe it or not did I
know it happened I remembered it when I
called my [ __ ] hand and you were
there on the phone yeah and I started
talking about it you heard us talking
about it that's when she became a
believer because they were reminded me
of things and I was oh yeah I forgot
about that
well yes the same story that you did
without any prompting yeah and I hadn't
talked to them in years and you hadn't
talked to them in a long time and I was
a kid at the time there were the adults
at the time they saw it too
and I had my theories about what it was
and it's just a strange phenomenon it
was a rare phenomenon I was lucky enough
to see it yeah and that opened my mind
to a lot of this but you know it's a the
thing about it is that so they
interviewed I mean on this you know 2018
documentary with Jeremy Korbel I mean
one Jeremy Korbel is in the [ __ ] a lot
you know also George Knapp is in it a
lot now he says and I don't know if this
is true or not but he's saying that it
was like you know Bob Lazar was very
reluctant to be on the documentary
George Knapp is like oh he doesn't like
to talk to people and he doesn't like to
talk about it anymore blah blah blah but
they did actually get out there and they
did get to talk to him and all this
other stuff and what he's saying now
he's like you know I'm tired of
defending myself it happened it's like I
don't care if people don't believe it or
not and he was saying that well it's if
anything it had a negative impact on his
life because I'm sure like people would
come out and say well you know
you did all these conventions it's like
you but I have to say though if that was
his house that they were filming it oh
he's doing good it's it's a nice house
he's doing good company though he yeah
and he has his own company they've
gotten in trouble a bunch of times but
it you know he's got a nice-looking wife
she needs to be a nice woman she seems
to be a nice woman now something that
they didn't bring up on the thing I'm
pretty sure that his first wife Carol
committed suicide I didn't know about
that by I saw that on the timeline what
by doing the garage the carbon monoxide
and the pipe sing homemade gas chamber
yeah I'm pretty sure she did that huh um
and I don't know if he was cheating on
her if he had like left her I think he
had left her at that point um you know
I'm kind of fuzzy on the details on that
they don't really bring that up a lot
but I just thought like on the timeline
I think that's the only place I ever saw
it but he did marry his new wife is
called joy so him and his wife have been
in some trouble with the law um now
first he was in trouble with the law in
1990 apparently this is going apparently
he was um a customer of a prostitute I
can't marauder name is I saw it like in
a vice article or something
they call him John's yeah he was a John
okay I don't know if this was when he
was married to the first one for the
second or FERS but in between marriages
but I'm not casting aspersions or
anything but so he so he would frequent
this prostitute and apparently she
wanted to open up her own brothel I
guess so he either gave her some money
or he was like helping her out now I I
should note that this was I believe it
was in Reno so it was legal but for some
for whatever reason he got in trouble it
was for pandering yeah what he had
there's certain licensing me yeah yeah
yes so it was so some kind of like legal
you know I mean he was he was actually I
think the arrest was for aiding and
abetting a prostitution ring but then
the charge was lessened two felony
pandering yeah
you know what I mean so he and they made
him go to like a psychotherapist and
also the judge was like he had
stay away from brothels like he wasn't
allowed to go on brothels anymore like
as a condition of the thing yeah
so no dispersions mean he had to do a
150 hours of community service
no dispersions I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
as a young soldier in a Korean in Korea
I also [ __ ] did business with the
[ __ ] professional leaders just [ __ ] a
rite of passage that every young [ __ ]
soldier has to go through when you go on
an overseas tour to the Far East yeah
it's just part of army culture so I can
understand it but you don't want to make
a lifestyle of that you know probably
not the best idea
hell no probably not the best thing it's
not it's not real it's not a real
girlfriend it's like screwing the
waitress well I'm you're just paying her
to like you like her pretend like she's
no there you pretend like they like they
don't know I guess it depends on it
depends on the woman yeah some of them
probably pretend like they like you a
couple of them did yeah you got to pay
extra for that uh I was [ __ ] melodia
better in Korea in Korea it was legal
and it was backed by the [ __ ] Korean
government it was a way of keeping
[ __ ] as much of the American
servicemen paycheck inside the Korean
economy it has helped fuel their economy
yeah and their war effort they're like
look if they got to be here at least
make them spend all their money
the South Korean government [ __ ]
would recruit entire armies of young
women and train them and speak in
English how to dress and how to be
entertaining to go out and make the
money in these nightclubs that had like
yeah apartments in the back and it was
like a nightclub it was like a full-on
nightclub and it was just American
servicemen and it was all [ __ ] okayed
through the US Army it's all gone now
but that's what it was back then yeah
and it was to keep you away from their
[ __ ] Korean civilians they don't want
these damn Vikings running through there
because that's what we were like we were
like the [ __ ] fire you know on the
weekends and [ __ ] drunk [ __ ]
American young GIS and rampagin just
rampage and I mean each one of a big
collection warrior cults I was from
[ __ ] camp Greaves up north and it was
like [ __ ] there's like a barbarian
horde man your head would you let us go
once a month 24-hour promise a month so
you went for we are all Pitts up you got
a like [ __ ] you got to have all that
fun in 24 hour guys don't know what I'm
talking about cam dreams us right next
to JSA right there where they hold the
peace talks we were right outside the
DMZ were the closest ones to North Korea
and it was a [ __ ] hell of a time man
it was [ __ ] wild so if you see where
they hold holding those talks are our
alpha company was at Camp Liberty Bell
which was their security for JSA JSA
guys are the ones that actually did the
talks but we were the backup the
security for JSA and we we were run like
a maximum security prison you were
either
you only got off one 24-hour pass a day
a month Carson when we were hardcore so
when they let you go you were you were
like a [ __ ] Viking man yeah it's like
I said you only on 24 hours before I
cram a lot of [ __ ] into there yeah a lot
of drinking like screwin lot there was
no wind drugs on the other side of that
no north of the M Jim River there were
no females yeah
no Steven Korean females there's aw man
not good
nah man I stir into that no no it was
the Don't Ask Don't Tell times but
[ __ ] that was a that for camp dreams
was a warrior cult unto itself it was
running like a ranger battalion yeah it
was the 506 man first the five or six
anyway and get ahead of myself I'm
drinking too much when we went down
range we [ __ ] [ __ ] up it had to send
us to a place to keep us occupied or we
get in trouble they knew what they were
doing the Koreans knew exactly what they
were doing yes they would senior like
before so they had whole armies of
17 18 19 17 was legal there 17 18 maybe
the 21 year old girls trained as like
geisha yeah you know to me escorts yeah
my geisha you know I mean they'll be
dressed up like a heavy-metal outfit or
they dress up you know just they would
dress up as a cowgirl everything was the
theme in a cheerleaders they not and see
that no cheerleaders yeah as soon as we
walked in they'd fall upon you depend on
how you looked you gotta man [ __ ]
they went for the cute guys first it's
just what it is you know that's the way
the world work is they you know somebody
who's easy to work with you know then
they take you up to their room it's like
[ __ ] Chinese Disneyland beautiful
it's beautiful beautiful in their
[ __ ] fountains and [ __ ] in the room
for the waterfalls in a room Baggins and
[ __ ] heart-shaped tub [ __ ] lights red
lights and green lights and [ __ ] no no
tubs make you take your shoes off where
you go in look at you you look very
because you didn't take your shoes off
automatically go off how about shoes
well yeah shoes are gross and dirty I
totally understand that I don't wear
shoes inside out but like I said it's
like screwing a waitress waitress
it's not a personal relationship yeah
it's not a personal religion that's all
it's just like your Waffle House
waitress like want some pancakes yeah
yeah yeah and then you kind of say like
and then like he's like let's go to
another club you know you don't want to
be around her let's start fresh you had
movement wasn't that the old I can't
member who said that but isn't that the
old joke it's not you're not paying the
prostitute for the sex your pain or to
go away yeah yeah yeah silence yeah but
yeah so poor old bob lazar got involved
with a is like I said the leave brothels
are legal there I believe is in Reno
Nevada but there was some kind of like
like he got trouble about and he wasn't
allowed to like it
brothels anymore yes so then the next
time he got in trouble with the law this
was him and his wife joy this time this
was in 2006
now they had opened this company which
is still opera in operation as far as I
know this was they have a chemical
company called United nuclear now they
don't have like it's this little shop
they showed it in the documentary oh my
goodness cookies nice so well that's
what you get for like sniffing all the
dusty [ __ ] over there um but they I
guess he like they don't have any
walk-in traffic like you're not a lot of
just like walking off the street and go
hey can I have some uranium but um you
know what I mean yeah but um they have a
website which I don't know if they've
updated it since I saw the website but
it's very very 90s CompuServe I mean
just saying it looks like an old 90s web
site so but you can buy like all these
unusual chemicals in [ __ ] now he got
raided the business got raided in 2003
and I think what they were doing was he
was selling chemicals for making like
illegal fireworks and he was like
selling them over state lines where he
was transporting them over state lines
which is pretty illegal so he got in
trouble for that
he also cuz he's like really into like
fireworks and pyrotechnics and stuff
like that like him and a friend of his
George Huff I think is that guy's name
he might've been on the documentary too
but they even started this whole like a
festival like out in the desert called
desert blast and it's like for
pyrotechnics geeks and like they just go
out there and just blow [ __ ] up for a
couple days like every year or whatever
but yeah so so he got in trouble for
doing that I believe one time and then
maybe like a second time later on I
think that he got in trouble for doing
that too likes just selling the thing
about it though it's like his website
that you know his really ugly like
outdated website you can go there and
you can buy like all this crazy [ __ ] and
it even like Senna's on there or it used
to I don't know if it still says this
but it even said on there that it's like
that
typically that they weren't gonna like
report you to the feds like if you
bought some of this [ __ ] because so he's
probably pretty aware that some of this
stuff is of questionable legality like
the stuff that he's selling so now
another thing that happened and if
you've watched the documentary and you
didn't look any further into this it
might like look look like he has some
kind of legitimate claim about his like
alien [ __ ] and how the government's
after him and everything so in the
documentary even from the very beginning
um you know Jeremy Korbel the dude that
made the documentary he gets like texts
from George Knapp and he's like oh my
god right now Bob Lazar is getting
raided by the feds and the documentary
makes it seem like he was getting raided
because another claim that Bob Lazar
made was that he stole some of this
alien element 115 and that the
government wants it back even though if
this element was what they later found
out to be Muscovy em there's no way that
you could you feel it because it would
be separate again you know what I mean
it flies apart I mean there wouldn't be
any of it left
yeah um but that was his claim anyway
and so he's saying that you know the
government's been trying to like they
had him under surveillance and they were
like trying to get back what he stole
from them like he kind of he didn't say
it outright but that's kind of what he
was implying now um so the FBI and the
local police did indeed raid the shop
and they did indeed have a search
warrant to search his house although I
don't believe that they search the
entire house because he did cooperate
with the investigation but unless you
believe in like super conspiracy
theories and it's all a cover-up and
everything it did not have anything to
do with area 51 or aliens or element 115
or anything like that what it did have
to do with was that in Michigan I
believe it was in 2013 there was a there
was a woman her name was Janelle
streusel she was 31 and she was murdered
by thallium poisoning which
bad [ __ ] yeah widget perfectly like that
kid like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that
kids name Graham young that one that
like poisoned all those people like
young poisoners handbook and all that
kind of stuff he used thallium a lot and
it's actually called the poisoners
poison because it's really really hard
to detect and it's really really toxic
and very very small doses
now valium does have some industrial
applications like they use it in glass
making and in electronics and various
other things now they think that the
suspect Bob Lazar is not a suspect in
this particular murder however they do
think that the suspect unnamed that
killed this woman may have purchased the
thallium from Bob Lazar from his website
and that is why there was a search
warrant because what ended up happening
was that and this is what Bob Lazar told
the investigators and this is like
vice-like fat did a whole thing about
this they did a Freedom of Information
Act and all that other kind of crap so
they got like all these public records
about what the raid was about so what
ended up happening was that you know Bob
Lazar he has this you know chemical
supply shop is essentially what it is
and I guess that he was contacted by
this woman whose brother had died and
the brother was I didn't even know they
had these but he's like an element
collector they're trying to collect
every element on the periodic table and
he had a collection like that this
brother and he died and so she was like
essentially gifting the collection to
Bob Lazar store and like saying you can
sell it now in this collection was some
phalion now Bob Lazar has claimed that
we did not self Allium previous to this
but that we got you know donated this
collection and it did have some valium
in it so we decided that we were going
to sell it and apparently one of the
people that purchased some of this
thallium murdered somebody with it
allegedly and that is what the raid was
about so or
that's what everyone says and now the
FBI were involved but I believe like I
said I believe it happened in Michigan
so it was the State Police but they
got the FBI involved not because it was
Bob Lazar because a lot of people didn't
even know who the [ __ ] he was but
because the state police were not
equipped to deal with this type of
poisoning case like they hadn't worked
with anything with thallium before and
and it was I believe the purchase was
made of her state lines or something
like that so they got the FBI involved
in that now in the documentary Jeremy
Corbyn made the claim that he's like
well a lot of the guys that showed up at
this raid said they didn't know who Bob
Lazar was they didn't know anything
about aliens or area 51 or anything like
that but he said that one or two of them
repeated something that him and Bob
Lazar had talked about like in a private
conversation so he was trying to imply
that they had them under surveillance
somehow or they had been listening to
them like through their cell phones or
something like that but I don't know cuz
that's only like his say so
I do kind of feel like I you know I
don't know I just feel like like I said
the whole thing about him having some
element 115 and having stolen it and the
government has been like trying to get
him this whole time I'm like you know if
they wanted to get you they would have
they know where your ass is he's not
like hiding or anything
he's been on radio shows he's been on TV
everybody knows what the where the
business is
you can order [ __ ] online from the
[ __ ] business it's like he moved it
around a couple times like it was in
Michigan and I think it was in New
Mexico for a while and I think he's like
moving it to Oregon or something like
that I don't know if that's like the
skirt laws or I don't know what he's
doing he's moving it around but I you
know I don't know it just seems to me
like this is something that a fanta
sister would come up with like I said I
don't think he's delusional I don't
think that but what private he's doing
is is that he's making this out to be
kind of like a they're persecuting me
because of what I know about the UFOs
yeah that's what he's doing
yeah he's trying to make it seem like
he's just constantly under surveillance
and that they're trying to frame him for
something right because he talked about
the UFO such adds credibility to
his UFO story that's what you do yeah
because everybody likes to like cry
persecution when especially when they
have like a crazy story like this that
they're coming up with but that makes
sense to do that because then that also
gives you cover yeah I sell some [ __ ]
rare elements yeah you can say oh I
didn't do that they framed me because of
my UFOs yeah you have those stories but
I mean I saw like all like copies of
like all the paperwork and all the
search warrants and stuff but the stupid
thing is that even though like I said in
the documentary Jeremy Korbel kind of
danced around the fact that it's like
while they were listening to us like
before the raid because one of the one
or two of the people like the FBI agents
that were at the raid because they said
it was a [ __ ] ton of people knew what we
had talked about like in a private
conversation with Linc out in the woods
or some [ __ ] like that but the thing
about it is that the search warrant had
been issued like for the house like a
couple of days before they even had that
conversation so it's not like oh we
heard them talking about it in the woods
and now we're gonna do the raid they're
like they had already filed for a search
warrant before they had that
conversation so I just I don't think
that that had anything to do with it I I
kind of think that they maybe maybe one
of the FBI agents said something a
little sideways or said something could
be misinterpreted or I don't know or
maybe they just made that up
cuz like I said you know Jeremy Korbel
he just seems like I saw this one video
I can't remember the name of the guy
that did he was like an Austrian he said
it Australian but he kind of did like a
half hour 35 minute like takedown of
this documentary in particular and he
was kind of like picking on Jeremy
Korbel because that dudes been on like
[ __ ] every TV every like radio show
and every podcast or everything like he
was on I think he was on Kjellberg and
he was on like a bunch of different ones
and he just he had edited together like
him saying the same thing essentially
over and over like he and even said this
in the documentary to how he went to
like weaponize your curiosity and he
said that on every single interview that
he was on so when it's all edited
together it just sounds like he had this
kind
Pat like spheal that he was giving which
I guess a lot of people do but he's a
showman yeah yeah okay III see these
guys as entertainers I think I see both
of them as entertainers yeah because
that's how they [ __ ] made their name
going on these shows entertaining people
who were interested in into into the UFO
scene that's what this is if you ask me
you know I don't like that but I saw it
for what it was as soon as your [ __ ]
25 and you start to realize that people
lie and sometimes there's not even a
reason for yeah
since you're 25 I just started to see
this as infotainment yeah it was like a
what-if you know man like what if this
[ __ ] was true maybe this isn't true
maybe there's something kind of like
this going on that's what that's how I
used to look at this [ __ ] but I hadn't
always enjoyed them Bob Lazar and these
guys and art bell and I just enjoyed it
even though I knew most of his [ __ ]
I don't know for some reason I just
can't I can't get into it cuz that's why
I could never really get into like a lot
of the art Bell type stuff or I'd go
into star nation aliens or anything like
I just start watching them like oh okay
I just like my eyes start rolling up and
I'm just like ya know in a way our show
is kind of like that except we're trying
to tell you we're trying to tell the
truth we're not well we're not making
anything up yeah we're trying to be
balanced about this [ __ ] and I mean even
we talk about paranormal stuff I'm
basically just telling you what other
people claim we're not saying that I
think it's true necessarily right well
we've both seen some [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
though yeah it just depends on what they
say yeah and that's kind of all you can
do they say I'm just like you know I
wasn't there so I'm not gonna say you
know and it's the same thing with like
Bob Lazar it's like you know is it
impossible that he was working at los
alamos and that he worked on like
reverse engineering alien technology
it's not impossible it's just the [ __ ]
that he came up with
he has specifically lied about a bunch
of stuff that can be proven and so it
just seemed
a lot less likely he doesn't seem like a
particularly credible mic source my
experience with government work at the
[ __ ] federal and state level I'm
gonna say no it's impossible they would
never let that dude near a UFO ever it's
like why me no but that's another thing
we were talking about this we were
watching the documentary it's like I was
like even if even if he did have the
credentials that he said he did what she
doesn't even if he did like his story
was basically that he just went in for
an interview with off the street he was
just sending resumes out like a normal
person never have yeah and he would just
get in there and like he goes to an
interview and like even did he even say
like before the interview was even over
they were basically like oh this is what
you're what you'll be doing by the way
aliens yeah yeah I think like they would
not do that that's what he said
that would never have ever that's what I
mean that would be super extra they
would be usually not sick they're top
[ __ ] contractors from their top
[ __ ] aerospace industries in their
[ __ ] with that [ __ ]
you know I mean dudes that had been on
many top secret programs already guys
that are T that were proven tested they
got just bring in some enough but
[ __ ] with them everybody do that
they're gonna be dealing with dudes that
were [ __ ] working on sr-71 style
[ __ ] programs guys that were [ __ ]
with space planes guys were messing
around with the [ __ ] that breaks
treaties like [ __ ] nuclear propulsion
you know internal and nuclear external
combustion engines [ __ ] like that dudes
that they know won't talk that's who's
gonna be on that
yeah because particularly in this in
something in an areas sensitive is that
you don't just want somebody that you
picked from a resume you you need
somebody that you know them you know
what they're you know they have some
kind of like career in it you know that
they have some proven record of like
whatever clearance that they have you
know they haven't blabbed about this
project that project that projects that
they worked on you have to have somebody
become some kind of history that you
know where they're coming from let me
just say some to the audience project
Orion was a nuclear external combustion
spacecraft it's been Declassified most
of it has been Declassified there you
should you should there are whole
documentaries on it on YouTube that you
can watch for free go research project
Orion alright that was 1960s alright
they canceled that Pro they cancelled
that program because of a treaty with
the Soviets the whole idea of [ __ ]
using nuclear propulsion Akana became a
taboo subject it was a violation of that
[ __ ] nuclear treaty that we do did
with them but if you think we didn't
break that treaty you're a child that's
all I'm gonna say
[ __ ] right we broke that and so did
the Russians there's all kinds of [ __ ]
out there that will never see the light
of day they'd be using guys that were
working on projects like that yeah to be
[ __ ] with a UFO because they know
those guys won't rat yeah that's the
thing it's like I know that there's like
all kind of like super top secret
operations and stuff like that but that
doesn't follow that they're necessarily
alien and origin they're just
governments doing secret [ __ ] that they
don't want anybody to know about
necessarily illegal well either legal or
because they don't want like you know
foreign powers or whatever like finding
out about it you know they don't want
them finding out about like what we're
up to over here so you can understand
like why they have that level of secrecy
it's just the problem is that the more
levels of secrecy you have the more
people are gonna come up with these wild
theories about what really is going on
back there what really it's probably
something boring or probably like
something but not boring but like not
alien technology I mean I would think so
that's kind of the same thing that I
wanted to talk about so I want to talk
it a little bit about area 51 in general
and the kind of all of the [ __ ] that
yeah and how that [ __ ] started that [ __ ]
started the skunkworks yeah
Lockheed Martin yeah and in its early
days staffed a lot of times by convicts
and ex-convicts like people don't know
that and people who couldn't read or
write did you know that well
it's actually a pretty smart strategy
yes yes indeed because you can't read
any like they can't read yes somebody
leaves something laying on the desk and
then yeah you have ex-cons in there who
are getting paid in cash who are totally
deniable you know what I mean what's he
gonna do go to the newspaper I used to
work on a secret program they're making
a damn space plane oh yeah where's your
pay stubs oh they paid me in cash
yeah you got a [ __ ] out of here yet yeah
they have ways of keeping [ __ ] secret
yeah
and you know if they want to keep
something secret they will yeah I'm just
saying so okay so the whole thing about
area 51 and I think the sad thing about
you know if it's sad but I think about
area 51 is that you say that and I think
everybody's mind the first thing they go
to is aliens ya know high plains yeah I
don't think there's anything to do with
aliens at area 51 I really don't is
their top secret [ __ ] going on there yes
yeah well provably there was top secret
[ __ ] going on there because it's been
Declassified now so we know that there
was [ __ ] going on there do I think
there's aliens or alien bodies or
anything like that no I dunno I just I
just don't think that and here's another
thing that area is old hat everybody
knows where that is yeah they're gonna
be doing some stuff there but a lot of
the real hardcore [ __ ] it's not gonna be
done there well yeah cuz everybody knows
everybody knows where it is if everybody
if they want to keep something really
secret they have to go like someplace
nobody knows somewhere out to see we own
a lot of islands that's one place I'd
look yeah there's we could make
artificial islands too that's another
thing huge barges do you know about that
yeah yeah well that would that would be
my first good run barges where you could
land a rocket yeah and yes you can't
land a rocket they're doing that now you
can land a rocket just like out of the
1950's they do it just up the street
here SpaceX just like it yeah just like
this 1950s sci-fi movies where they just
boy they just ran the film in Reverse
yeah but they've been working on that a
long time now they can do it they're
like finally we finally achieved it and
every be science fiction project
in the film the project Orion nuclear
nuclear propulsion spacecraft was going
to be launched from a [ __ ] gigantic
barge out in the middle Pacific Ocean
because it just rolled on a huge [ __ ]
wave of superheated [ __ ] nuclear
plasma is that [ __ ] launched itself
out of the damn atmosphere it weighed it
was the size of a 30-story building it
weighed what a battleship weighed that's
how [ __ ] massive it was it was solid
steel and concrete it was not a
spacecraft as you would imagine it's a
day would be like launching a damn
battleship or a skyscraper that's how it
was [ __ ] it and the engine was
basically a coke bottle machine yeah you
know the coke bottle bottling machine
that's what the engine was it threw out
three atomic bombs per second out of the
back of it and it just [ __ ] it it's
just for hit it made a modern rocket
[ __ ] feeble compared to what they
were gonna do man
it could get to [ __ ] Mars in just
like a couple months you get to Saturn
in a few months and come back they had
they had technology far in advance what
you think and it was basically 1930s
technology aside from the atomic bombs
yeah but that was only 40s and they knew
about the atomic type [ __ ] in the 3rd
20s and 30s they were already theorizing
it but the Cooke bottling engine was
like 30s technology imagine what they
could do now yeah you probably don't
want to imagine there's all kind of
crazy [ __ ] going on now but yeah so if I
were gonna do some weird [ __ ] secret
[ __ ] I'd be out on a barge somewhere
deep in the Pacific Ocean can you be
controlling other people's spy
satellites they couldn't see it yeah or
out somewhere like on a place like
Bikini Atoll well that's where they did
all the atomic testing yeah or you do it
in a friendly country where nobody's
watching somewhere down in ur required
Paraguay they look over there we're
gonna blow some [ __ ] up yeah southern
hemisphere yeah araguaia proof Paraguay
maybe Australia something like that or
the [ __ ] out back there yeah or
there's I think there's some islands
around that area yeah north of Australia
that'd be a good place to look if I was
a u.s. contractor I'd be buying getting
permission to work in a place like that
yeah yeah well the thing about area 51
which I mean that's not its official
name really it's actually called Green
Lake or honey Airport they actually they
first bought the land the Air Force
rather they bought it in back in the 50s
and it was initially for the development
of the u-2 spy plane which at the time
flew at a higher altitude than any any
other plane and obviously they they
wanted a secret place to like develop it
as why and test it and everything like
that without the Soviets find out about
except during the Cold War so that was
why the site was first established why
it was top-secret and everything but
they still knew about it though that was
the thing well yeah that's the thing
it's like you still knew about it it you
can be like a secretive as you want but
seized like the other government they
have the same they have smart people too
and it's like they have secret [ __ ] too
so it's like they know what you're up to
we would fly the u2 over on the [ __ ]
shoot missiles that we see that yeah
reach it but they would try to shoot it
down they eventually did get a missile
that would reach it they knew where it
was landing and everything they knew the
timetables they knew what time it took
off they knew yeah like I said that's
people not dumb people aren't stupid
yeah and it's like they you know people
can put two and two together especially
if you have like another and these are
all scientists too and like engineers
and stuff so they're like well if it was
me
how would I do it yeah they knew where
it was coming from there's nothing to do
about it right so but that kind of
marked the end of the March the end of
[ __ ] secret bases out and groom like
you could test [ __ ] there but everybody
knew you were testing [ __ ] out there
there's just what anything I can do
about it yeah and I mean the thing about
I was watching a thing about it today
and they're like you know
yes it's some of its remote they use it
as you know a testing range training
range [ __ ] like that
usually working on spy planes other
types of LaRose no drones experimental
aircraft for that kind of stuff
but they're like everyone knows where it
is there's a fence there's a thing that
says area 51 so it's kind of hard to get
to
like you know there's not like a you
know real road it's like a little it's
got its own Airport and you gotta fly in
honor you got to get into a plane that
flies it to that ya groom lake and it's
only like 80 miles from Las Vegas or
something yeah and everybody flying on
that plane that's how they get to work
they don't drive to work they flying on
that plane every day yeah it's kind of
cool when you think about it so it's
very secure you can't drive to work yeah
they fly into work yeah they don't let
anybody know although I was reading it
like what they do is they have like many
concentric rings of security they're
like normally what they would do if
somebody like kind of breaches the
perimeter but doesn't look like they're
doing anything nefarious like they just
maybe wandered onto the land without
realizing or whatever they're like um
they won't necessarily do anything to
you but they'll just like keep you under
surveillance the whole time to make sure
you're not up to any [ __ ] um and they're
like if you just kind of wander back off
the [ __ ] then it's fine they're not
gonna do anything about it
but if you steep still keep like coming
in there um you basically get like a few
layers of like hey get off the [ __ ]
land hey you know it's a Warren then the
helicopters will come and then if you
get like far enough in though they'll
just shoot your ass you know what I mean
and they have signs like posted like
this saying as much security contractors
in there yeah so because of that and
like I said because this was established
during the Cold War and they were
working on a bunch of experimental
aircraft that they didn't want anybody
to know about because there was so much
secrecy and security like surrounding
the base and also because there was a
lot of UFO sightings around this area
once the base was opened all of these
rumors started swirling in the late 50s
that they had aliens in there they had
like captured aliens are like working on
some type of alien technology or you
know that there were aliens and they
were like working with us like
establishing you know various things and
so I think that is kind of where that
idea came from and even it isn't there
even a thing with you know that the this
quote-unquote like aliens that crashed
in Roswell all the little bodies and
everything that that's where they took
them to area 51 that that's yeah that's
they said but there yeah we got to do a
she program on that but the Roswell on
the Roswell we probably said yes yes
it's an interesting story it is it is do
I think it was extraterrestrials
probably not no I don't think so either
well I think it was a top-secret but I
don't think it was aliens same with area
51 it was the story we have wouldn't
match that in other words you know I
mean it's a [ __ ] alien story yeah to
cover up a real alien story if that if
it was aliens the chances are don't
think it was I think was a project mogul
balloon I do tell ya I mean it just
seems like I don't know I was watching
something else about that about you know
that whole thing earlier and you know
there's like oh this guy that said he
used to work there on his deathbed he
said no it was for real aliens I wasn't
allowed to say anything and stuff but
you can't you can't just take someone's
word for [ __ ] especially like when
they're dying they could be suffering
from dementia or whatever [ __ ] with
you they're trouble or [ __ ] with you
because that would be hilarious yes your
last [ __ ] actors like when you're
dying and it's like by the way it was
aliens the whole time yeah I mean or it
could have been that he thought it was
yeah that's another thing too and it's
like a lot of the [ __ ] that um that we
talked about like it was the alien
abductions and ghosts everything like
that
I'm not calling all of these people's a
lot of people's liars I'm just saying
that they could have been mistaken or
they could have convinced themselves
that that's what they saw or somebody
else convinced them or someone else
convinced them because look it's pretty
easy to plant a suggestion in someone
else's head especially when someone's a
kid you know yeah young or vulnerable a
long time ago and time is kind of erased
yeah your memories are not as good as
you think they are so if somebody keeps
telling you that hey this happened this
way after you'll probably start to
remember at that lake and they've done
like cite likes you know psychological
studies where the more you repeat like a
memory even if it was something
it really happened to the person but you
changed some details the more you repeat
that the more they will begin to like
form their own memories of it happening
that way and after a time they will only
remember it the way you told them even
though that's not the way it happened
yeah well truth a lot of time is the
truth and reality is a lot of times just
kind of in the way you describe it - you
can characterize things yes as being a
certain way and you can make that real
in your own mind and then another person
can characterize it in a completely
different way and they've made it real
in their minds and really what it is is
that the truth of the matter might have
been more gray instead of black or white
depends on the open to interpretation
you need a current any occurrence yeah
well I'm just saying to that like say
for example and I've heard about um you
know I'm pretty sure I'm remembering the
vague details of this but they've done
studies where for example let's say that
there was a kid and they had like a
birthday party and they got like a
particular present for that birthday and
it was videotaped like their family
videotaped that birthday party now later
on they start telling that kid hey you
remember that fifth birthday party you
had you got this present you got a box
of Legos and you keep telling them that
and telling them that and then later
they remember getting a box of Legos but
you show them the video and actually
they got star wars figures they didn't
get a box of Legos and they will watch
that video and be like that is wrong
right I got a box of Legos because
they've been told that so many times
that they completely like replaced the
memory of the actual event which was
videotaped with a memory that was
essentially implanted well it makes
sense I mean here's something to [ __ ]
blow your mind no matter how old you are
now let's say you're 20 years old or
older every one of your cells that was
in your body when you were 10 is gone
and dead you're a replacement of
yourself by this time I don't know how
memory is passed on all those brain
cells have been replaced by other cells
by that it's not made of you it's kind
of like a little brain cell relay yeah
you know what I mean it's like one of
the braces like I'm dying
I'm dying here take this yeah it's not
as good as it was originally but here
shake it a run with it so really well no
I think it when you look back to
yourself [ __ ] 30 years ago that's not
even yes not even really want to say you
know level every one of those cells is
gone I mean you still got your same DNA
and [ __ ] all your cells have your DNA in
them but yeah it's like an old clone of
you that's dead well it's essentially
like it I've seen it compared to this
it's essentially like making crappy
Xerox copies yeah of yourself earn over
and they will you make a copy and then
you copy that copy and grab your shitty
copy it's only you only got like the
original when you come out as a baby and
then like every test like you just you
just keep copying in that essentially
when you're like 80 or 90 years old it's
just this shitty like [ __ ] well
pixelated and [ __ ] so even though like I
said there had been [ __ ] going on at
area 51 since the 50s so I think that
people that lived around there and you
know because they had seen like weird
lights in the sky and they knew that
there was some kind of military presence
of its offenses and everything like that
so kind of all these rumors grew up that
there was like some weird [ __ ] going on
there now the government didn't help
matters by like denying everything up
until I believe this 2013 right that was
like the first time they actually were
like yeah you got us area 51 is there
and we've been doing like top-secret
[ __ ] there the whole time and everyone's
like yeah tell us something we don't
know but they did finally like say what
it was but I do feel like like a lot of
people have come out and said what maybe
because like I said there was a lot of
um you know quote-unquote UFO sightings
like around there but they didn't really
start until the base opened and I've
heard like several pretty credible
people say that they thought it was
probably some kind of particle beam
thing like generator that was making
like all these weird like plasma lights
in the sky that people were seeing like
out in that area it wasn't like UFOs or
anything and also some of it obviously
might have been some of the weird planes
that they were flying sidon to work on
the stealth bomber and all that kind of
[ __ ] there was that it that was that it
area 51 the stealth yeah they were
working on yes yeah
and I think that a few because I
remember here in a few like UFO reports
right around the time before that the
stealth bomber became like public
knowledge in the description that they
gave sounded essentially oh yeah stealth
bomber there was one from like the very
early 80s where a woman said she was saw
something fly over her she was out in
the country came over the crest of a
hill she was down in the valley it flew
over she saw it head-on coming towards
her pretty much lights on it black and
she drew it spot on frontal view [ __ ]
so she wasn't crazy she did see
something it just wasn't it
so people were seeing things so I think
that a large amount of like you know
UFOs that were seen around that time
period were probably either just
particle beam like so from the particle
beam generator or were you know
experimental planes that people weren't
familiar with well a lot of them were
but there were also sightings that look
a good UFO sighting would be like the
Tehran UFO that was a good one
the upand sightings which is in France
Phoenix lights you know there are some
good [ __ ] sightings yet there but
Lazar I consider Lazar to be an
entertainer yeah because a lot of like I
said a lot of the claims that he makes
just can't be verified it's like I want
to call him a liar a liar is a dude in a
bar telling you some [ __ ] okay
I consider Lazar to be a [ __ ]
entertainer he did a circuit and he went
on shows and he told you a [ __ ] story
that was entertaining
it was infotainment of the era and
people do like to hear but I mean like I
said it's it's not I mean probably the
reason we haven't done like a lot of UFO
shows because you probably are more into
like UFOs and alien I love UFOs yeah
that I am it's like for some reason I
don't know for some reason I don't find
those stories like all that compelling
not because I don't think there are
extraterrestrials it's just I guess
because a lot of the stories are just
kind of like say me and then most of the
pictures or they have videos or
something like that
none of them really look like anything
all that exciting and so I don't know I
guess it's just kind of like it's the
same reason I'm not like really excited
about Bigfoot stories or anything like
that I'm not saying that there's not
Bigfoot's or big feet or whatever you
want to call them there might be but I
just feel like most of the sightings of
them are probably [ __ ] or you know
it not people making it up but just
misattribution you know what I'm saying
well there's another - there's a
documentary on YouTube
I think it's called beyond belief and
you can find it it's in pieces on you on
on YouTube it's a forgotten
documentaries really good what year was
the from teen uh 90s the cops two
different police forces saw a [ __ ]
flying triangle I remember seeing that
one yeah and he even got a photograph of
it but all you sees the lights on it one
cop did yeah and the cops were all
calling each other they got all the
recordings of the cops saying which way
it was going you know I mean it was I'm
gonna go there and see if I can see it
and it was a flying triangle I'm not
sure was extraterrestrial though that's
what I mean it's like a lot of them I'm
not saying that like all these people
are not sir they don't know what they're
looking at I think some of them are
seeing weird [ __ ] because I've seen
weird [ __ ] in the sky too and I still
don't know what it was I don't think it
was an alien spacecraft it was a flying
triangle it had a [ __ ] awesome light
array on it but that light array I could
cut I could explain that as a urban
camouflage yeah if you have a military
aircraft why not disguise it as an alien
aircraft see that's what I would do
because that way no one would really
horde it and nobody believes you right
it's because you can't hide it you're
gonna see it yeah so you might as well
dazzle the [ __ ] out of something but
then you tell them it had lights all
over and it ahead of it was an alien
spacecraft and like get the [ __ ] out I
feel like you'd they would just think
you were in that case right so it's
pretty genius like a deception yeah when
you think about it what I think it was
this is my theory based on other things
that I heard from guys are really into
this and
into aviation history I think there
might have been a series of aircraft
from the Reagan era okay near the Star
Wars SDI store ta offense initiative as
to shoot down incoming ICBMs yeah back
in those days men you need some
high-powered [ __ ] radars to do that
kind of [ __ ] alright I think you took a
solid body Zeppelin huge Zeppelin's who
can be heavy lift they're very heavy
lift yeah you can put a huge radar array
and it's something like that and move it
around to where needed to look over the
horizon for incoming ICBMs you disguise
it like a UFO and you don't tell anybody
you have it why because it violates a
treaty yeah why because it's
nuclear-powered all right yeah you have
a nuclear reactor generating steam
driving a [ __ ] electric generator and
it's silent using in ducted fans it can
move itself around silently it's
remote-controlled nobody in it it can
stay on station for months without
having to land like a nuclear submarine
yeah except in the sky except in the sky
with a huge radar array in it that's why
it's so big
yeah I mean that's what I think it was
see I think that's actually a lot more
likely than an alien spacecraft I think
it's something we made and like you said
if they were trying to keep it a secret
just whatever look likely you make it
look like a UFO so nobody sees it they
don't believe it yeah either they don't
believe it or when they report it
everyone just thinks they're enough
legit right right because they're like
hey I saw you at psychological warfare
yeah that's essentially what it's
actually kind of genius what do you
think about I mean it's it's a really
good strategy that's like some [ __ ] I
would do yeah so cuz like you said you
can't hide it especially if it's
something like really big and for
whatever reason it for whatever project
were doing it has to fly over like a
population tear it's a half a mile
wingtip to wingtip because it's a solid
body Zeppelin yeah with a gyre
our emitter in it that requires a lot of
power so it has to be nuclear and if the
Soviets find out you're [ __ ] because
you're violating the treaty so you you
make that [ __ ] you dress it up
like a UFO with a bunch of LED lights in
it give it a dazzling display yeah so
when you tell them when you tell people
about it you look like a fool yeah and
then it's like even if it does get on
the news and I'll just be one in one of
those news of the weird section yeah and
everyone will be like that's crazy yeah
that's what I think it was thanks like
an alien's some of the flying triangles
I think that might be what it is if this
video gets censored it's because that's
what it because you got it right
yeah damn it he guessed but yeah well
that was like I don't think it's gonna
get censored just because of that
because that was one of the things that
they say about area 51 like among many
other things like with the [ __ ] that's
going on there is that back in the day
they used it for Star Wars like the SDI
energy weapons and that kind of stuff so
that was one of the rumors that was
circulating that that was maybe one of
the things that were working on SDI yeah
yeah they have that now yeah laser
weapon isolated right is you seen that
kind of stuff isn't crazy and I think
that's probably what they're working on
out like you said drone technology
lasers all that kind of stuff cuz I
don't really know I don't think they do
a lot of aircraft anymore and as far as
I know it does seem like UFO sightings
around that area have declined well man
is it a heyday manned aircraft are on
the way out that's what I mean I think
that's why people aren't really seeing
them like they used to because I think
most of the old ones they were seeing
we're experimental aircraft and when you
think of these Predator drones that
could just fire missiles that's it
that's actually old hat you know what I
mean uh-huh
the next way of a drones are gonna be
drawn fighters that can take down any
[ __ ] manned aircraft they can outfly
any manned aircraft carrier carrying
weapons on them or they're [ __ ] they
have [ __ ] very sharp leading edges
and they can fly through and Ram a
[ __ ] manned aircraft cuz it's a drone
yeah they were gonna Ram manned aircraft
with manned aircraft back in the days
but can I would not want to be that man
yeah
Northrup made a flying wing called the
flying RAM and it was a hick who draws
the short straw to fly that [ __ ]
thing it was a little baby jet it's a
little bitty jet it was just a flying
wing and you laid down and it was very
narrow with an armored front
leading-edge there's before guided
missiles this is back in the 50s they
had guiding militant guided missiles but
they weren't any good right so you
[ __ ] launched this thing is Point air
too fancy flew after a [ __ ] incoming
nuclear bomber and you ran right through
it cut his tail off that [ __ ] well it
was armored yeah you know I mean you're
only talking about most of these
aircraft are aluminum so if as long as
your aircraft is sharp and strong on the
leading edge you can go through it yeah
and it's one man and you're laying down
worst-case scenario you could bail out
you got time yeah you don't to me if you
lose control because you're doing this
at high altitude so it'd work better
than a missile of the day you need some
[ __ ] brass balls to the ekadesha well
you got to stop an incoming at a nuclear
bomber yeah one man given his life to
save his day if the whole city yeah so
that was the thinking yeah but yeah so
like I said SDI
was supposedly going on area 51 also um
you know Roswell alien bodies obviously
we should do a whole thing about [ __ ]
Roswell and alien autopsy and all that
autopsy remember that came out man that
[ __ ] that man everybody was talking
about that [ __ ] but you know I watched
it over and over again I rented it cuz
they hate you really they had it at my
[ __ ] video I picked it was huge after
I watched it like a couple times I'm
like no well they weren't the people
doing the autopsy did not know how to do
an autopsy
yeah pathologist and I know that's not
how you do it out yeah it's just pull
this out and throw it in the [ __ ]
scale that's not they're not measuring
anything they're not [ __ ] they're not
doing anything that you would do if you
were autopsying an actual alien you know
what I mean it's like a butcher yeah
they were just doing that it was like a
horror movie more than like a scientific
like autopsy I've seen like human
autopsies
like on TV and stuff I was thinking on
do them like I was making excuses for it
I was like well they don't really know
anything about alien Anatomy so they're
just doing their very basics there's
like reason there what the hell is this
[ __ ] now they would start within a
cellular level they did a lot of x-rays
and they would try to they wouldn't want
to cut into it first well yeah why would
you yeah because once you cut into it
yeah you got to do everything you can do
before you leave that up right it's just
and they would be taking like little
samples or like all the tissue like all
the different parts and and it would
have photographed the [ __ ] out of it
from every [ __ ] angle yeah they would
have done all kinds of takin they would
have actually taken microscopic shots of
it you know me with a microscope in its
eyes everything yeah you get like the I
juice the blood well you get all I taste
everything right I mean you'd think it
would want to know everything about it
I'm gonna say and if I was gonna make an
alien autopsy it would be I would be
better than that I went to a good high
school we did [ __ ] vivisection and
dissection of frogs okay we did frogs
turtles sharks the the cats the PERT
they're already dead
well yeah yeah and the turtles and [ __ ]
like that the turtle was alive that was
we did we didn't do we did a live crab
but I think the turtle was dead the
turtle had its frontal lobes have been
destroyed the professor stuck a needle
through it so it was it didn't need
anesthesia it was mindless but but it
still had it's on an autonomic system
it's still breathing it [ __ ] it stayed
alive for a week while we were that's
horrifying I'm totally open it up and
you could close it back up and it would
start to heal weird that it was pretty
was alive but they'd be doing stuff like
that to it'd be real gentle you know
yeah with it and it would be a real real
um it would be a real precision
procedure and that's not what they were
showing yeah it just seems really
half-assed yeah like I said it seems
like a horror movie conception of like
what an alien autopsy would be not an
actual alien autopsy not quite as she is
not quite as [ __ ] cheesy is that
[ __ ] mermaid documentary they're
trying to pass [ __ ] discovery a real
alien autopsy they wouldn't have removed
anything they just
cut into it move things out of the way
and then put it back in you know when
they were done with it and moved on and
take it they'd been taking photographs
every step of the way yeah and taking
samples and then they would have froze
the whole thing yeah it's just it I
don't know it's just something about it
rubs me the wrong way and also I had
like there wouldn't be two people in the
damn operating room there'd be about 30
yeah another thing too is like I was
reading something about in a while back
and they said like a pathologist came on
and said well the guy that's doing the
autopsy is not even holding the scalpel
correctly like the way a pathologist
would hold it yeah or even the way a
surgeon would hold it it's like he's
just he's doing it wrong
so these are clearly just like actors
yeah just came in there did that there'd
have been 30 dudes watching that and
they'd all be talking about it every
step of the way yeah you wouldn't it
would have taken a long time it's just
well it's just funny that you can do
something that half-assed and like you
know 50% of people will like buy it like
it's a little thing without really
thinking about it I guess people don't
really think about stuff they're just
like oh okay
it was another time yeah that to you
although look at some people some people
fell for that mermaid [ __ ] - and that
was my dad fell for the bells only a
couple program looks like the mermaids
might be real thousands years thousands
of years they knew the mermaid even
ancient Egypt knew back of mermaid what
are you talking about what that's what
they call a mockumentary I didn't know
what he's talking about we watched it
and I [ __ ] remember I called him back
so dad I saw that [ __ ] man that was no
man he didn't know what a monkey because
yeah he didn't know he didn't he didn't
know that there's like a whole genre of
that's called mockumentary where you're
it's supposed to look like a real
documentary but it's not a real
documentary and you know not only can
old people not handle TV they can't
handle TV the Internet they're very
confused just watch the news you see how
they'll fall for the news to [ __ ] you
know it's not they think it's the same
news as it was from 20-30 years ago it's
not it's Authority various they're into
authority figures and I guess that
worked on people back then it's like
that's what kind of like cracks me up
about all this old like um all those old
educational shorts things they show Mun
like MST and RiffTrax and yeah and it's
just like how funny how they have some
authoritative a lot of them are a lot of
them are narrated by beavers dad yeah
you know what I mean well there's
actually a psycho there's a lot of
psychology behind it
authority takes stress off of people
well yeah because like well because you
don't is somebody else's do you they're
taking their responsibility right and so
like if something messes up it's not
your fault that whole generation loved
Authority it made him feel better
because they didn't have to worry about
it they're doing it they got it under
control
they they handle it I'm just yeah
experts her own it gonna be over here
with my blue stake in my high ball I'm
just like that guy and they were into
[ __ ] you know titles you have a title
in front of your name and [ __ ] that they
know what they're doing no they don't
the doctors and scientists can be wrong
just like everybody else well everybody
can be wrong like you know what I mean
it's like it depends on what your area
of expertise is like I said you know
some people believed Bob Lazar because
it was erroneously reported that he was
a physicist what I'd like one he's not
it looked like when he sounded like like
when he talked he kind of sounded like
if you didn't know anything about you
know if you just had like say a high
school understanding of physics or
chemistry or whatever he did sound like
a smart guy and he sounded like he knew
what he was talking about but people
that actually know about those kind of
things like immediately like you know
he's full of [ __ ] like he has no idea
what he's talking about yeah but so but
over the years to tell you what the
institutions have kind of declined I
mean there are a lot but really we can
go back hundreds of years professionals
and people of people with authoritative
titles have had a piss-poor track record
over if you go if you take an account
history
yeah I mean there were people that there
were people that believed all
consecrating think they had crazy things
that had titles well a hundred years
from now they're gonna look at our
scientists like they were [ __ ] well
on the thing too is that once because
there's so much information there's so
much knowledge and really only one human
brain can only hold so much of that so
anytime you stray outside of your area
of expertise you are just as prone to
being mistaken about something as anyone
elses that doesn't know anything about
that so even if somebody is a physicist
say and you know they can ask you about
economy well they could be completely
brilliant in that field that's it but if
you ask them about something else it
doesn't necessarily mean that they're
automatically going to be wrong about
other things or write about other things
they're just as likely to be right or
wrong about it as anyone else's because
that's not their area of expertise
that's all that's another thing that
we're dealing with the modern education
produces specialists the specialists are
especially their specialists at their
specialty old education is like back in
the 1700s in the 1600s there were more
generalists they could combine a lot of
things together but now there's too much
knowledge you can't do that because you
know I mean back in the days you could
have a guy who's a statesman he knew
about biology and physics and chemistry
but it was 1700s yeah but back in the
old days when like you had dudes like
you know Charles Darwin and something
they knew like everything everything
because there wasn't was a whole lot of
no right
I can't imagine everyone knowing every
you know it's you could learn you could
know all of man's knowledge back in the
17 days it was maybe like a dozen books
or yeah I'm exaggerating but yeah but it
did create a certain kind of generalists
intelligence yeah they could combine a
lot of [ __ ] fields together and and
they could come up with some pretty cool
[ __ ] because they could think in a bunch
of different directions yeah nowadays
you know a specialty is so specialized
well because there's almost much there's
so much
it almost you almost end up making an
idiot savant yeah
which and I was and that's the thing I
don't know if there's any way to avoid
that you know because we know so much
nowadays I might like frizzes I'm like a
dumbass okay for instance I would know
I'm a dummy yeah when I lived in Boston
I was go to the clubs and a lot of the
guys have a show up to the club [ __ ]
would be from MIT and Harvard and
[ __ ] Tufts University and they were
very [ __ ] specialized in what they
did they were [ __ ] geniuses but only
in that [ __ ] field right if you
[ __ ] knew what they were like him
personally and partying in their
personal lives in the in [ __ ] in
everyday life they were [ __ ] dumb
asses dumb asses like they didn't know
anything about women you know or how
people worked they all [ __ ] they they
might have a [ __ ] experiment going on
on the space shuttle or up on Skylab or
some [ __ ] like that yet I mean but
they're [ __ ] dumb when it comes to
people or when it comes to something
outside their field but they were
geniuses yeah so that personal
experience really kind of taught me not
really to listen to them only when it's
about something they know about just
like just kind of a general good rule
it's like yeah it's like I'll listen to
you if that's what your area of
expertise is I mean they would ask me
about stuff and this dude's a genius but
they knew it nobody can be a genius
they're not a genius in everything and
like I said especially nowadays like you
said back in the old days it was pretty
you know I'm not saying it was easy but
it was a lot easier who's easy to be
like a lot more broadly educated because
we didn't know as much you know what I
mean so there wasn't I was thinking
about this it's weird this is the kind
of [ __ ] that I think about when I'm like
just walking around in the morning I was
thinking you know even when I graduated
I got graduated from high school in 1990
and I was thinking that it's like that's
been you know however many years that's
been 30 years or whatever and people
that are graduating this year it's like
they have 30 extra years of history of
science of everything like that
what I had to learn
and it's like they're not giving them
any more time to learn that you know
what I mean
it's yai is gonna dominate probably only
sentient computers are gonna be able to
do with this who the hell can keep track
of all that each other I can't keep
track of all that [ __ ] that's why it's
gonna end up being like something out of
dune where machines will control man and
men who control machines will control
man
that's eventually what will happen
that's what's happening now cuz I mean I
like to think my bird tell dictating
what reality is
men who command controlling machines and
the machines that control man yeah it's
me just like I I mean I say [ __ ] all
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] list perfects
human ability just like I'm a dune man
and the new dunes coming y'all gonna
love it I think that I think the new
dunes gonna be good well it's the same
guy that directed [ __ ] Blade Runner
to a moment ago and I love that movie
from what I hear that was gonna be good
so I mean I've I've heard good things I
don't know you see how it turns out at
least somebody's [ __ ] doing it yeah
it seems like they're into it yeah but
um yeah so but what I was saying is that
I like to think that I mean within a
fairly narrow like I have a lot of
general interests and you know I've i'm
very widely read on a wide variety of
topics um you know i'm really into like
science and music and art and all the
art history and all this other kind of
stuff
so i like to think that i have like an
okay like general education about
various things but it's like even me I
kind of feel like and this is something
I think about a lot too because there is
a thing called the dunning-kruger effect
which I'm sure most people have heard of
where's like if you only know a little
bit about something but you think you
know everything like the less you know
the smarter you think you are type of
thing that that's actually revolves you
know and a lot of people have that I
think people that are actually smart or
actually educated are actually
well-informed know how much they don't
know so they tend to be more circumspect
about it's like look man it's like I
know a little bit about this that and
the other but it's like that's like a
whole other thing and I don't know
anything about that whereas it's easier
if you only know like a couple things
about
to think oh I just know everything about
everything you know what I mean so it's
like it sounds contradictory but it
really does kind of like come across
like that I try to stay focused on
people I'd like to understand people and
human nature and systems and human
systems how one system interacts with
another because I think life is centered
around people not so much technology and
you know I mean so if you can understand
people and what drives people then you
right then I can predict what what can
happened in the world the way I see I
mean it's an interesting I I just feel
like because I feel like we're kind of
in an unprecedented time where you know
we have sort of this interaction between
human and technological advances that we
never really had before and so I don't
know like how it's gonna go I'm not
pessimistic about it I'm not optimistic
about it either I'm just like I'm just
kind of waiting to see what's gonna
happen it's interesting to me it's
interesting how it's gonna go I don't
think AI and robotics is in man's best
interest ultimately probably not I think
it has to be [ __ ] stopped or you know
I mean it you have to freeze it at a
level that we can all deal with and then
I think we need to [ __ ] re-educate
mankind to learn to find your own human
potential we have to admit what human
beings are and we have to put human
beings to good use and from my
experience what a human is made for is a
human is made for exploration we all
need to be exploring the [ __ ] stars
that's ultimately what we need to be
doing if we just stay here on this
[ __ ] planet we're just gonna [ __ ]
fight we're gonna be [ __ ] out
[ __ ] [ __ ] ever [ __ ] [ __ ]
and we're gonna [ __ ] destroy
civilization we need to get these
[ __ ] off to plant it and build
another world I would volunteer to go to
another world as long as it was nice and
quiet and there was not that many a lot
of these hostile badass [ __ ]
that are causing trouble here the reason
why they're doing this because they're
bored they need to be out [ __ ] like
you used to do
in the Age of Exploration need to be on
a damn ship explored and that would take
a lot of the problems away yes put upon
a [ __ ] spaceship your ammo base ship
you guys are gonna [ __ ] go and check
out this other star system you're gonna
sleep for [ __ ] 30 years you'll wake
up you'll be check out Bob Lazar claims
killer whatever aliens what you guys
despite the aliens and a lot of the
problems will [ __ ] - because they'll
be doing what human beings do human
beings are in an aggressive and an
expansive species well and a curious and
curious right and that serious and we
always want like new experiences and
that's what humans were evolved to do
that's what we've been doing going from
one continent to the next from one
jungle to the next from going here that
and that's why humans are malfunction
and do it in the [ __ ] because the
challenge isn't there you know I mean
and it doesn't take high intelligence it
just takes balls okay or ovaries
depending on well you know I'm talking
about they need to get those [ __ ] the
dudes that it's cause and [ __ ] need to
be out doing something yeah that's why
the cause and [ __ ] cuz you're not using
them for what they're for exploration
well it's just kind of like what they
say you know every time that Pookie
causes trouble yes because she's bored
him because she's bored and not pay
attention she's like I'm just gonna tear
your whole room up and all your stuff
[ __ ] your blu-rays window-blind yeah
pull the blue race out of the damn
[ __ ] cabinet I went though him on the
floor I went into the walk-in closet
other morning I just got up and I walked
into the walk-in closet turned on the
light like to put on my clothes got
walk-in Pookie was sitting in the
walk-in closet there was just a vast
array of blu-rays and little books and
photos and stuff like that she had
pulled off that shelf yeah and they were
just all around and she was just sitting
in the middle just looking innocently up
at me like yes that Mommy yeah look what
I did yeah
she very carefully like pulled them all
out and arranged them and then said and
then waited for me to come in
there yeah we're gonna hit by a storm we
did end of show oh yeah the end of this
is the end of the Tsar we covered Lazar
we probably I'm not gonna [ __ ] talk
[ __ ] about Lazar I think he's an
interesting character he like a nice man
seems like a nice guy I don't want to
call him a liar Mercy's entertainer I
think it was all infotainment and I had
a good time listening to those are
stories that's that's that's all though
I have to say I can't really recommend
that documentary that was on Netflix
because it just I don't know there was
just something I didn't really like
about it
it just seemed simple oh I forgot to
mention that Mickey Rourke narrated it
yeah and he just comes on he sounded
like he was hired wrong as [ __ ] yeah and
it's like some like all the narration
that he was just like this really weird
like poetic I don't know what the [ __ ]
he was saying he was just like rumbling
deep yeah they were like trying to boost
like some Deepak Chopra type of [ __ ] or
whatever yeah except was swearing and it
was just like I was just like what the
[ __ ] hell is he talking about how did
they get him to do this did they like
give him some cocaine or what I don't
know but it's like it was really weird
he was great [ __ ] [ __ ] thanks Ben
I like I love Mickey Rourke have you
ever seen the wrestler oh you need to
see the wrestler you [ __ ] love that
movie I saw the theater shut it down I
quit dismissed yeah
yeah because yeah it's it's starting to
lighten under everything like that we
probably will lose all right so we're
gonna wrap up episode 198 about bobbles
are an area 51 I know we got to do
Illuminati livestream yes Illuminati
we got a like start playing in that out
okay but yeah so I hope you guys have
enjoyed episode 198 and remember if you
like the show like share subscribe on
all your social media if you'd like to
financially support show go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
where is calm and there is a button in
the sidebar that goes to a PayPal
account if you'd like to have a one-time
donation any amount is much appreciated
and helps us continue the show and we
will see you
next time by
[Music]
you
[Music]